Keck-Weight
Oh nein, ich hab übelst Muskelkater
in den Beinen
Ich hab mir noch so ne Fitness-Uhr gekauft
Ich hab mir gedacht, ja lass doch mal kurz tracken
wie schnell ich
so 3 Kilometer rennen kann
Das war keine so gute Idee
Am Ende waren es 3,3 und ich dachte
danach eigentlich, ja gut
das ging doch halbwegs
also hab ich übelst Muskelkater in den Beinen
Ich bin das nicht gewohnt
Aber ich hab ja die Hoffnung
dass wenn ich das öfters mache
Ja, das kommt auch noch dabei
Das ist richtig
Aber ich hab ja die Hoffnung
falls ich das öfters machen soll
dass es dann nicht mehr so schlimm wird
Warum warst du davor mit dem falschen Encounter?
Hast du gebannt
auf Twitch
Ja, aber das stimmt wohl
Wobei ich glaube, Muskelkater liegt weniger am Alter
mehr am nicht in Übung sein
Also ich bin auch nicht sonderlich schnell gewesen
Also ich kann euch das
Moment, ich kann euch das glaube ich sogar sagen
wie schnell ich gewesen bin
Moment, ich muss mal kurz die App
die App aufmachen
So, Kalender
Ich kann euch das sagen, wartet mal
Ich glaube das war am
Freitag
Hier
Ja, also
Steht das da irgendwo
Erster Kilometer hab ich gebraucht
8 Minuten 24
Zweiter Kilometer
hab ich gebraucht
8 Minuten
Das ist so, naja
Ja, nächster Kilometer
hab ich gebraucht, 9 Minuten 6
Ja
Komplett
Ja, ich wollte mal gucken, ob ich so 3 Kilometer
Ich bin am Ende waren es 3,3
war die Strecke lang, wie lange ich das
durchhalte, letzten 300 Meter
bin ich ein bisschen schneller gerannt, vielleicht war ich deswegen
dann auch so im Arsch
Ja
Ich hab im Internet mal geguckt, das ist so ein typischer
So ein typischer Einsteiger
Speed
8 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer
Aber ob ich das nach dem Muskelkater
öfters mache, weiß ich nicht
Also ich
Ich bin das am Freitag
bin ich das geflitzt, 3,3
Kilometer
In Wirklichkeit waren es 4
In Wirklichkeit waren es ein bisschen mehr
Ich bin am Anfang ein bisschen normal gelaufen
3,3 bin ich die restliche Strecke
gejoggt
Und heute ist Sonntag
Morgen und ich hab immer noch übels Muskelkater
in den Beinen
Weiß nicht wie lange so was geht
Naja
Eigentlich schon mit dem Sub
Neste
Uneste
Company
Das wird besser, je öfters man das
Ja, das ist ja bei so ziemlich allen Sachen
Aber ich muss sagen, es ist tatsächlich
nur in den Beinen
Nicht irgendwie großartig Rücken
oder Arme
Also ich das letzte Mal zum ersten Mal
seit langer Zeit ein bisschen gerannt bin
hatte ich übels Muskelkater in den Ärmen
Aber jetzt ist es nur in den Beinen
Ja also
Und ich war dazu
auch nur motiviert
Also so weit komme ich
nicht im Leben
Das Einzige was mich dazu
tatsächlich ein bisschen motiviert hat, ist halt
dass ich mir so eine Fitnessuhr gekauft hab
und die hab ich eigentlich gar nicht gekauft
zum Tracken vom Rennen oder so
Also eigentlich wenn ich
meine normalen Daily Runden mache
wollte ich halt einfach mal gucken und aufzeichnen
wie viel Kilometer das alles so sind
Da dachte ich mir so gut
guck doch mal ob du
diese kleine Runde da durchhältst
Also
ich war schon ziemlich im Arsch
Ich war schon ziemlich
Ich meine es ging, aber ich war schon
ziemlich kaputt
Und wie gesagt, ich hab übels Muskelkater
in den Beinen
So, dann lasst uns doch jetzt gleich mal gucken
Nicht Geizhals
GitHub, ShitHub, ShitHub Weekly
Was gibt's denn außer AI
AI, jawoll, wer hätte das gedacht
Ha
AI
React UI braucht keiner
Fullstack
GUI Library
Für Rust, ich will in Rust sicherlich kein
UI Zeug programmieren, Rust ist schon eh
anstrengend genug zu programmieren
Und dann noch UI, ich weiß ja nicht
Ja, sieht auf den ersten
Blick nicht so
schlimm aus, aber man sieht schon
ganz viel, Moment
Das ist
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie JavaScript Zeug
Das ist jetzt nicht TSX, nee JSX
Sondern es ist RSX
Siehst du, dass es dafür schon
irgendwelche Makros braucht
Weißt du schon, irgendwas
ist da im Argen, was
Rust und Rust Libraries angeht
Und das ist jetzt auch ein schönes Exampel
Lasst uns mal die anderen Exampels angucken
Die sind bestimmt
nicht
Ja
Da kommen wir schon hin, das Rust hat nicht so
Ja, ich meine
Es ist Fake HTML
Obwohl es kein HTML
Moment, kopieren Emojis?
Das ist neu, oder?
Seit wann
Seit wann gibt es
hier ein Emoji Menü, wenn man rechts klickt
Und die große Preisfrage ist
Warum?
Warum gibt es
hier ein Emoji Menü?
Moment, Moment
Seit wann gibt es ein Emoji?
Seit 2018?
2018?
Das ist mir noch
Moment
Ist das vielleicht auf normalen Webseiten
Ach so
Ah ja
Was empfiehlt Google
heute sich anzugucken?
Eher weniger
Ach, das ist
weil das hier ein Codefeld
ist, deswegen zeigt es das an
Jetzt verstehe ich das
Okay
Also hübsch ist es wirklich
nicht anzusehen, muss ich echt sagen
Also ich verstehe, dass Rust relativ
viele Fans hat und auch viele
Fanboys hat
Aber schön zu lesen ist Rust
oftmals nicht. Also ich habe schon
Rust-Source-Code gesehen, da ist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger
die komplette so
120 Zeilen, quasi Code
Zeile voll mit
irgendwelchen Dingern, die
sehr unleserlich sind
Das ist auch so typisches Rust-Zeug
Und
Rust ist glaube ich
Ich glaube Rust hat noch mehr Sonderzeichen in der
Syntax als C++
Was es nicht unbedingt schlechter macht
Weil eigentlich so gut wie nichts schlechter
sein könnte als C++
Aber Sonderzeichen ist
schon, ich glaube Komplexität
von der Rust-Syntax ist wirklich enorm
Ja
Das ist auch so ein typisches
Rust-Ding
So
Wusste gerade auf dem
Vorschau-Monitor was gucken
Okay, so was haben wir denn sonst noch
Ja außer, dass ich Muskelkater
als Fuck hab, ist alles gut
Keckel
Keine Ahnung
AI, China-Chinesen-Zeug
AI, Wim
Wim
trendet?
Warum trendet Wim?
Der Wim-Erfinder ist gestorben
letztens
Woher der Muskelkater?
Weil ich hab mir noch eine Fitness-Uhr gekauft und ich wollte mal gucken
Wie schnell ich so eine 4km-Runde
rennen kann
Ich bin eigentlich nur 3,3km
gerannt
War ja ein bisschen eingelaufen
Ja
Und es war nicht sonderlich schnell
Aber es war anscheinend sehr
anstrengend
Weil das war am Freitag, es war Freitagnachmittag
Und ich hab heute immer noch, gestern war ganz schlimm
Ich hab heute immer noch Muskelkater
als Fuck in den Beinen, aber glücklicherweise nur in den Beinen
Nicht, nicht im Rücken
und auch nicht in den Ärmen
In den Ärmen hatte ich letztens übelst
Ja, ne, ne
Mit Wanderstelz hab ich kein Muskelkater mehr
Das mach ich ja jeden Tag genug
Ja, aber
3,3km
joggen war für mich zu anstrengend
Ich wollte
einfach mal gucken
ob ich das hinkriege
Ich war auch nicht sonderlich schnell
Ich hab's euch ja gerade vorgelesen
Ich hab irgendwie im Durchschnitt irgendwie
3, ähm, Quatsch
8 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer
gebraucht
Wenn man im Internet guckt, ist das auch so
ziemlich das, was so normal ist
für Einsteiger
Warum trendet Wim auf einmal
Wie gesagt, ich dachte der
Kann es sein
dass die jetzt ganz viel merchen
Was der Erfinder
vorher nicht wollte, oder wie ist das jetzt
Es tut sich enorm
viel, oder?
In Wim
Guck mal, das hier dürfte das letzte
Das hier dürfte das letzte Comet
vom
Das war sein letztes Comet
Das ist der
Wim-Erfinder
Letztes Comet, 9. Juli
Ja
Ja, mittlerweile merk ich das
Ich bin jetzt ja auch fast 40
Kurz, aber nicht mehr allzu lange
Jetzt sterben
langsam schon die Leute
deren Software ich benutze
Ich mein, Linus ist auch nicht mehr
der Jüngste
Also die sind alle mittlerweile schon ziemlich
alt, ich ja auch
WebDev for Beginners
AI, AI, AI
Home Assistant
trendet, zu Recht
AI, AI, AI
Juckt mich alles nett
Jaja, der auch
Die sind alle ziemlich alt schon
Ich mein, so diese
First Generation
IT
Computerpioniergeneration
die ist ja schon zum größten Teil
sehr alt oder schon gestorben
Ja
Ja, das hoffe ich auch
Vor allem braucht der eine
Nachfolger, der da auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen ausflippt
Ich mein
Linux Kernel Entwicklung wäre nicht mehr
das gleiche, wenn da nicht ab und zu mal
einer übelst ausrasten würde
Wobei man ihm echt zugute
halten muss, er hat ja
vor ein paar Jahren mal gesagt
er ist jetzt reformed
er ist irgendwie ein halbes Jahr
in sich gegangen und will jetzt
nicht mehr so ausrasten
und das
hat anscheinend auch funktioniert
also ich glaube seitdem
sind seine Ausraster
deutlich weniger geworden
der ist im Vergleich zu
früher mega entspannt
geworden, also früher
gab es ja
wöchentlich irgendwelche größeren Rants
aber mittlerweile
kommt das wirklich selten vor
dass der sich mal aufregt
das letzte was ich mitgekriegt habe ist
worauf er sich drüber aufgeregt hat
dass Intel
kaputte Netzwerksachen
kommitten wollte
irgendwelche Leute von Intel
hat er sich übelst drüber aufgeregt, aber irgendwo auch zu Recht
und dass der
Intel Typ dann so abfällig
drauf geantwortet hat, hat ihn natürlich noch mehr
ragen lassen
und
das ist das letzte was ich mitgekriegt habe
im Vergleich zu früher
rastet er kaum noch aus
wobei man halt sagen muss
das weiß ich jetzt aber auch nur vom
hören sagen, aber kann man im Internet
kann man nachgucken, dass das in Schweden wohl
äh nicht in Schweden, in Finnland
dass das in Finnland wohl
relativ verbreitet ist
dass die Leute viel fluchen und mit Schimpfwörter
um sich werfen
das scheint da eher
da bist du ja gar nicht
scherb angeguckt, das ist wohl in Finnland
fast normal, dass du den ganzen Tag am meckern
beziehungsweise am meckern, so am rumfluchen bist
es scheint
so etwas finnische Kultur zu sein
also wir können auch froh sein
dass Linus das so lange macht
weil überlegt euch mal
da hätten, also er hätte da nicht
so die finale Sicht drauf
wer weiß wie viel
Enterprise Business Shit
bei Linux abgehen würde
wenn
er da nicht an der Position wäre
also, keine Ahnung
ich hoffe er macht es noch lange
ja
und dann mal die wöchentliche Erinnerung
kennt irgendjemand eine gute
IT News Summary für die Woche
bisher habe ich keine
gefunden und auch alles was mir
empfohlen wurde, fand ich nicht gut
Heise und Golam haben das eingestellt
Weekly Summaries zu bringen
oder zumindest wenn, dann bringen sie
die zu spät für Sonntagmorgen
ja also
das heißt Dünnschiss
auf Finnisch
die Pirate Bay Typen kommen aus Schweden, keine Ahnung
wo die herkommen
Torrent ist doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt
selbstverständlich
hat jeder von uns Torrent nur
zum Linux Distributionen unterladen
benutzt bisher, stimmt's?
dann würde sich ja nichts anderes
würde man da machen
gegoogelt oder wusstest du das?
ich hab's gegoogelt, das wusste ich nicht
ja
eventuell
auch noch für selbst angelegte
Sicherheitskopien, aber
nur für Linux und selbst angelegte
Sicherheitskopien würden wir Torrent verwenden
jetzt mal
ernsthaft, ich hab ewig
nichts mehr, sei es Linux Distribution
oder eigenhändig angelegte
Sicherheitskopien, ich hab ewig
nichts mehr über Torrent runtergeladen
magst du an's Trinken erinnern?
ich hab ewig nichts mehr
mit Torrent runtergeladen, hochgeladen
auch nicht, das ist schon
wirklich lange her, ich würd sagen
das ist über 10 Jahre her
dass ich wirklich Torrent
mal ernsthaft benutzt hab
ich kann mir das mit 10 Jahren immer ganz
gut merken, weil 2013
bin ich hier in das Haus eingezogen
in das Haus vom Opa
und dementsprechend weiß ich
seitdem kann ich mich
an keine
an keine Torrent Usage
mehr
erinnern und dementsprechend
weiß ich gar nicht, was da so
aktuell angesagt ist
ah
und Chat, was hab ich verpasst die Woche?
ich war die Woche ja nicht, glaub ich war nur einmal
lass mal kurz gucken, wann war ich denn zuletzt on
mobile
ja guck mal, vor 6 Tagen
das war quasi am Montag
Montagabend war ich
zuletzt on
dreieinhalb Stunden
fast ne Woche her
ja, was wollt ich jetzt eigentlich sagen?
ich sollte nicht
auf dem Vorschau-Bildschirm irgendwelche Sachen reingucken
ja, ich war lange nicht mehr da
hab ich irgendwas verpasst? War die Woche
irgendwas spannendes? Also, lass mal überlegen
hab ich
irgendwas mitgekriegt? War irgendwas
so IT-mäßig? Also diese ganze
Microsoft-Token-Geschichte war letzte
Woche? Ich glaube
nicht, oder?
Ich glaube nicht
also zumindest nix, wo ich mich dran erinnern könnte
ja, ja stimmt
das war
tatsächlich, das hab ich mitbekommen
das ist eine
.NET-Library, die jetzt E-Mail-Adressen scannt
wobei ich da sagen muss
ganz ehrlich, also
ich muss da mal
kurz was zu sagen
vielleicht haben das manche Leute mitbekommen
wenn nicht, erzähl ich euch das mal
es gibt auf GitHub eine Library, die nennt sich
MOC
das ist eine Library fürs .NET-Ökosystem
was sie macht, ist auch vollkommen egal
so, und da gab's letzte
Woche ein bisschen Drama
und zwar
der Maintainer von MOC
hat also, das ist eine relativ beliebte
Library, die wurde auch ein paar
Millionen mal schon runtergeladen, wenn man sich
die Nougat, guck mal hier
es hat 478 Millionen Downloads
wenn man sich das anguckt
und der Maintainer
von dieser Library hat noch ein zweites
Projekt, das nennt sich Sponsor-Link
Sponsor-Link soll
irgendein Webservice werden, wenn ich
das soweit richtig verfolgt hab, um
bessere Spenden-Verteilungen
für Open-Source-Projekte irgendwie zu ermöglichen
ich hab mir das nur am Rande angeguckt
zumindest hat er letzte Woche
Sponsor-Link in MOC eingebaut
und das .NET-Ökosystem
Internet ist halb
explodiert, weil
was passiert ist unter der Haube
das ist ja auch blöd gewesen, ja
dadurch, dass er diese Sponsor-Link-Geschichte
eingebaut hat, wird jetzt bei jedem
Compile-Vorgang
mit dieser Library dabei
wird jetzt ein
Command-Line-Befehl ausgeführt
um die E-Mail-Adresse
aus der Git-Config auszulesen
dann wird die E-Mail-Adresse
gehashed und
an Sponsor-Link geschickt
damit man quasi
überprüfen kann und dank des Nachrichten
in der Compile-Message anzeigen kann
wer sponsort das Projekt und wer nicht
und sowas, ok
also, dazu muss ich echt mal
zwei Sachen loswerden, das erste ist
es ist eine ziemlich blöde Idee gewesen, das einzubauen
vor allem nicht
sagen wir mal so
offensichtlich darauf hinzuweisen, um das Ganze
Opt-In zu machen
oder zumindest etwas
breiter zu kommunizieren, das war blöd
was aber auch blöd ist
ist, wie komplett die
Leute wieder eskaliert sind
ich find's komplett affig, muss ich euch ehrlich
sagen, also ich verstehe, dass die Leute
keinen Bock mehr haben, das dadurch zu benutzen
dass die Leute sagen, ok
sie können jetzt quasi keine
Library gebrauchen, die
automatisiert E-Mail-Adressen auslässt
sie trauen dem Library-Autor nicht
mehr und sowas, das kann ja jeder für sich selbst
überlegen und kann sagen
ok, das will ich nicht mehr machen, aber
diese Welle der Empörung
die auch heute noch, wenn man sich mal in die Issues
reinguckt, ja
die auch immer noch anhält
ich mein, guckt euch das mal an
wann haben GitHub-Issues, wenn's nicht wirklich
was richtig Großes bekannt ist
wann haben GitHub-Issues
Comments
und die Leute haben's komplett
übertrieben, ich mein, man darf an der Stelle
ja auch mal, denke ich, nicht vergessen
oder man sollte es an der Stelle mal erwähnen
die Library gibt's schon ganz lange
der Typ hat nie Geld dafür genommen
der hat die weiterentwickelten Maintains
seit vielen Jahren, komplett
ehrenamtlich, kostenlos
viele Unternehmen verdienen ihr Geld
mit Projekten, die diese Library
verwenden und das hat er alles
für, ja, just for fun
gemacht, so, natürlich hat das
jetzt verkackt, dadurch dass
er so Sachen eingebaut hat, wie
dass E-Mail-Adressen ausgelesen werden
aber wie manche Leute darauf reagieren
haben, ja, also das ist
wirklich unter aller Sau, also ich kann's
ich kann's verstehen
wenn nach solchen Beispielen
keiner Bock hat, irgendwas mehr open source
zur Verfügung zu stellen, beziehungsweise
das weiter, weiter zu maintainen
da machen's die Leute, wie ich, ja
die releasen irgendwas und kümmern sich dann
nicht wieder drum
ich mein, wie viele
Issues hab ich mittlerweile
ok, das ist ja auch nur ein kleines Projekt
18, ja, selbstverständlich
liegt das nicht an Fehlern von mir, sondern
nur dass die Leute nicht
wissen, wie man's verwendet, zumindest
zumindest haben das
ein bisschen, also ich finde
es gibt zwei Sachen, es gibt
zwei unterschiedliche Ansichten dazu
so, also
die ich nachvollziehen kann, ja
das erste ist, dass die Leute
sich beschweren und sich
persönlich quasi, ähm, wie soll ich sagen
was ist da das richtige Wort für
ja, bisschen angegriffen fühlen
oder auch genervt fühlen, dass
eine Library, die sie verwendet haben
die sie gern verwendet haben, die ihnen auch viel
Value bringt, letztendlich vielleicht
für sie nicht mehr verwendbar ist
und auch die Art und Weise nicht gut finden, das verstehe ich
aber, ich mein man muss mal
in diesen Thread hier reingucken, wie da
manche Leute drüber schreiben
so als ist der Typ jetzt ihnen in irgendeiner Art
und Weise verpflichtet oder
sie verlangen jetzt, dass das und das
passiert wird und wie die da über den
Autor reden, der ehrenamtlich diese
Library maintained hat
komplett
kostenlos und komplett ohne
irgendwelche, äh, ja
Aufriss drum zu machen, die letzten
keine Ahnung, acht
Jahre oder wie alt das ist
also, die Leute denken
glaube ich, dass das rein durch das
Benutzen dieser
Library sie jetzt in irgendeiner
Position wären
als hätten sie
als hätten sie das, keine Ahnung
als wären sie irgendwie an der Gründung
des Projekts beteiligt gewesen oder so
also als wären sie irgendwie Core-Maintainer
oder sowas, nur weil sie das benutzen
die Leute sind mir da
viel zu, viel zu
wie soll ich sagen, viel zu
moralisch, so wie da drauf so nach dem Motto
ah, ich sehe das so und so
und deswegen muss das jetzt so gemacht werden
ja, genau, das denke ich
mir auch, das Ding ist open source, wenn sie es
wirklich machen wollen und wenn es ihnen so sehr auf den Sack geht
können sie sich das Ganze forken und selbst
maintainen, was ja auch einer probiert hat
wo ich meine Zweifel habe, ob das so
Traction aufnehmen wird
er hätte natürlich
auch ein bisschen schneller zurückrudern können
mittlerweile ist das Ganze ja raus, mittlerweile
wurde das Ganze ja entfernt, allerdings
hat er einen Fehler gemacht und zwar
er hat das Ganze entfernt
er hat Sponsorlink
entfernt
weil es angeblich
Mac OS Builds
kaputt macht, ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass er es entfernt hat
wegen Public
Geflame und dass er
vielleicht sogar eingesehen hat, dass es keine gute Idee war
aber, hey, man kennt die
Leute doch, niemand sagt
gerne, okay, habe ich scheiße gebaut, war eine blöde
Idee, ich entferne das
der hatte halt so den Kompromiss gewählt, der hat
gesagt, ja, ich entferne es, aber
weil es Mac OS breakt
natürlich hat das die Leute dann auch wieder aufgeregt
weil die gesagt haben, okay, das heißt in Zukunft
kommt das wohl wieder rein
es haben sich wahnsinnig viele aufgeregt
aber, also
eine Sache, die mich wirklich, wirklich nervt
ist, wenn man sich auch die Comments durchliest
für wie selbstverständlich
die Leute es halten, dass
jemand in seiner Freizeit kostenlos
eine Library mit 400 irgendwas
Millionen Downloads maintaint
und durch das pure
Benutzen der Library, die
Leute irgendein Recht daraus ableiten
ihm vorschreiben zu können, was er machen soll
ja, also, das finde ich
komplett übertrieben und ist komplett
lächerlich, was da wieder gelaufen ist
also ich kann, wie gesagt, ich kann bis zum gewissen
bis zum gewissen Grad beide Seiten
verstehen und ich kann auch verstehen, wenn man sagt, man möchte
die Library nicht mehr verwenden, aber
dieses
ich weiß es besser und dadurch, dass
ich die Library benutze, bin ich
jetzt irgendwie, die Leute
es ist ja sogar noch schlimmer
nicht, dass die Leute irgendwie
anerkennen, okay, der Typ hat sich jetzt jahrelang
kostenlos um diese Library gekümmert
worauf viele große Projekte
auch zugreifen
nein, die Leute sind auch noch der Meinung
dass, weil sie die Library
benutzen
sie jetzt quasi das
große Opfer einer Verschwörung sind
so, wenn ihr das so durchliest hier in den Kommentaren
so nach dem Motto, oh nein, wir verwenden
diese Library, der Autor
ist ganz furchtbar böse, weil
dadurch, dass sowas eingebaut ist
bin ich, wurde ich
Opfer eines
DSGVO-Verstoßes und sowas
ganz viel, sowas steht da
guck hier, guck hier, hier
hier
da kommen die Leute, oh nein
DSGVO-Verstoß
nicht, dass
sie noch ankommen mit, man muss den Library-Autor
verklagen und sowas
die sind komplett lost im Kopf
also viele schreiben
ja hier auch sehr sinnvolle Sachen, aber umso
weiter, umso weiter
diese Diskussion geht hier
umso
abgedreht
umso mehr drehen die Leute ab
und sagen
sie können ihm vorschreiben
was er machen soll
naja, zumindest irgendjemand hat das auch
geforkt
ah fuck, da muss ich mich einloggen
irgendjemand, kann man das auch nicht so nachgucken
irgendwie, doch, lol
achso, das ist, wenn man auf fork klickt, will man
versucht ja das selbst zu forken
es haben ganz viele Leute geforkt
aber die Frage ist halt
ist halt die Frage, ob das irgendwie
wie
Geschwindigkeit bei der Entwicklung
aufnehmen wird, ich persönlich denke
ja nicht, also ich gehe davon aus
das ganze wird im Sande verlaufen
und zwar
der
Autor wird es wahrscheinlich
jetzt mit dieser Art und Weise gut
sein lassen, was er versucht hat, ich glaube
ihm ist eingeleuchtet, dass es eine blöde Idee war
und der Fork wird nicht weiter
verfolgt werden
weil ganz im Ernst
die Leute haben gar keinen Bock, das zu maintainen
und wenn sie es versuchen, merken sie
wie nervig das durchaus
sein kann
und wissen es dann vielleicht auch mal zu schätzen
dass sich einer hier seit 8 Jahren oder wie lange es das gibt
oder noch länger
um eine Open Source Library kümmert
ich meine, wir können mal gucken, wann das erste Comet war
das ist was, was mich auch bei Github nervt
warum gibt es hier unten keine Seiten, warum gibt es nur
ich meine, klar, ich könnte mir das Repo jetzt klonen
oder so, ja, das mache ich jetzt auch
keckel
ist halt dumm, dass man das machen muss
ich hole mir jetzt das Repo
und gucke, wann das erste Comet war
gibt es eigentlich einen
Dependency Injection Service für Mock
ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, du weißt
dass Tests
sind bei mir eh überbewertet, dementsprechend weiß ich auch
nicht, wie man Mock gescheit verwendet
ach, zieht er eigentlich schon für den Sub
so, hoffentlich ist meine 4M gestartet
ok, dann lasst uns das mal kurz klonen
ich will mal schnell schauen, wann das erste
erste Comet
2007, Leute
alter, 8 Jahre, bitte was
ich hab gesagt, seit 8 Jahren
maintain, der hat
diese Library 15 Jahre
so muss man sich mal auf der Zunge
zeigen, also 15 Jahre lang
gibt es die Library
gibt es die Library Open Source
und er maintaint das, updatet das
und stellt es den Leuten zur Verfügung
es ist eines der beliebtesten
und größten Nougat Libraries
schlechthin würde ich mal sagen
also
ja, ich verstehe, dass die Leute
angepisst sind, aber jetzt so
zu tun
als ist das der komplette
als würde das
alles quasi
ja
so wertlos machen
dass einer seit 15 Jahren
da seine Freizeit für investiert, ich weiß nicht
also die Leute sind irgendwie teilweise nicht ganz dicht im Kopf
nee, aktuell
regen sich die Leute auf
was ist MOC, ok, ich versuche
das mal kurz zu erklären
also, das ist, im Prinzip muss man
es für den ganzen Skandal, ja
muss man es für das ganze Drama nicht wissen
was MOC ist, MOC ist eine Library für .NET
Library aus dem .NET Ökosystem
das viele Leute verwenden
das verwenden viele Leute zum Testen
ihrer Software
nicht wirklich zum Testen, sondern
Teil, im Teil ihres
Testprozesses, ich glaube die haben hier auch
ein ganz gutes Beispiel
für, ja, genau
hier, du kannst zum Beispiel
wenn du
beschreibe ich jetzt, wenn du irgendwas testen willst
kann es ja durchaus sein
dass du
Instanzen
von Objekten, von Klassen
brauchst, die rein
im Test eigentlich gar nicht sinnvoll
zu instanzieren sind, zum Beispiel
du hast irgendeinen
API-Client
der sich einloggen muss, gegenüber einem
Live-Service und alles mögliche, so
das kannst du jetzt bei einem reinen Test schon ja schlecht
machen, ja, du bist in einer
Testumgebung, du bist vielleicht auch nur bei dir auf dem Recherche
du kannst dich nicht irgendwo
bei irgendeinem Live-Service einloggen, den es gar nicht gibt
also musst du das irgendwie MOC'en
also sprich, du erstellst
das Objekt mit
ja, im Prinzip
was von außen so aussieht
als ein gültiges
API-Objekt zum Beispiel, aber ist es gar nicht
es ist nur gemockt und dafür kann man
halt diese Library verwenden
zum Beispiel, der legt hier
eine Instanz von
einer Klasse mit
einer Klasse an, die dieses Interface implementiert
und dann kannst du das danach
verwenden, so
als hättest du
quasi eine gültige Instanz von der Klasse
auch wenn es vielleicht im Test-Kontext
gar keinen Sinn macht, dass man die überhaupt
anlegen kann, aber nachdem ich
eh nicht teste, weiß ich das auch nicht
aus erster Hand, ja genau
nächste Woche kann durchaus sein, dass er die Entwicklung
einstellt, das ist übrigens auch nicht
gar nicht mal so weit her
geholt, erinnert
sich noch einer an diese Rust
an diese Rust
HTTP, an diese Rust
Web-Server, Web-Framework-Library
wo die Leute dem
Entwickler, Leeraks, Dankeschön für den Sub
wo die, oh, Besos muss ins Weltall
Leute, wo die
Leute dem Entwickler so sehr
auf den Sack gegangen sind, dass er teilweise
Unsafe-Code-Stellen hat
dass er irgendwann gesagt hat, er hat
keinen Bock mehr, die Library zu
maintainen, weil die Leute ihm auf den Sack gehen
ich bin mir nicht, oh Dankeschön hier
Leeraks, 5 Subscriptions, Pogu
extrem
Nice
der hat hier Glück gehabt
der Schreiger95 auch, der ist auch schon
öfters am Start, Spudimann
hier, du hast richtig
Glück gehabt, ich hab dich hier noch gar nicht oft gesehen im Chat
gleich Sub abgekriegt
und der Nico, der ist auch öfters am Start
wobei, doch, ich hab
das stimmt nicht, ich hab gerade mal auf dich draufgeklickt
du warst ja schon öfters am Start
hatte ich jetzt aber, gut, ich kann ja auch nicht alle merken
du bist dabei deinen Rekord zu brechen
weiter, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, wir hatten sogar schon
Subtrain
Level 5 und sowas, Twitch erzählt
auch ein Blödsinn, hä?
SlimBeatz, Dankeschön für den Sub
ach, das stimmt gut, ich war ja fast
seit einer Woche nicht da, es ist ja mehr oder weniger
Monatsanfang für mich
ne, das ist nicht
Besos, das ist der Zuck
will doch, ja, ich hab
sogar gelesen, dass zur Zeit
in der Überlegung ist, ob
Elon Musk und
der Zuckerberg, ob die
nicht im Kolosseum sich aufs Maul hauen können
anscheinend muss der
italienische
frag mich nicht, römische
Kulturminister oder so
angefragt haben, so nach dem Motto
wollt ihr das nicht im Kolosseum machen?
DerLachs am Start
Dankeschön für den Sub
Isl87, der Spudimann
hat subscribed, hat, hat
gegiftet, Möpp am Start
Poggleute, danke für die ganzen Subs
hä, das ist doch schon eine Weile am Laufen
dass die
erst, erst so
fast vor Fun geplant haben
sich aufs Maul zu hauen
und dann hatte irgendwann die Oma
von irgendeinem, glaube ich, oder die
Mutter von Elon Musk gesagt, Jungs, beruhigt
euch mal, und dann
und jetzt, und jetzt nimmt das
konkrete Formen an, ne
ja, aber um das mit der Library mal abzuschließen
wie gesagt, bin mal gespannt, wie sich das Ganze
entwickelt, ich persönlich denke
das, das
werden die jetzt so gut sein lassen, der Typ lässt
Sponsoring in der Art und Weise raus
und die Leute lassen den Fork sterben
und gut ist, ich glaube, das wird sich alles wieder beruhigen
weil auf Selbstmaintain
haben die Leute eh keinen Bock, Selbstmaintain
suckt, machen wir heute Rust
schon wieder?
Du meinst Rust Rewrite?
Kein Rust Rewrite
Ja, macht doch nichts
Habt ihr auch schon erfahren, dass die EU-Richtlinie
für austauschbare Akkus absolut nichts
bringt? Ne, hab ich nicht erfahren
Ich hab das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
so mitgekriegt
Was ich dort mitbekommen habe, ist das mit
USB, dass Apple natürlich wieder
extra Wurst machen will, also sie unterstützen
USB-C, aber dann
nicht für schnelle Datenübertragung, nur zum
Laden, blablabla, das war doch klar, dass
da irgendwas wieder drumrum gewurstelt wird
Würdet ihr heute noch WDS
verwenden und gibt es bessere Alternativen?
WDS, ist das dieses
WLAN-Authentifizierungsding?
Oder was ist WDS?
Achso
Windows Deployment Service
Dazu kann ich nichts sagen
Ich hab keine Ahnung
von Windows
Vielleicht kennt sich da
einer im Chat mit aus, Chatgear ist ja
bekanntermaßen extremely
six-head, aber
davon hab ich keine Ahnung
Stufe 3, Leute
Die Rakete hebt fast ab
Moin, Leute
Schön, dass so viele am Start sind jetzt schon
Ist ja recht früh gewesen, ich war glaube ich
um halb 30 oder so schon am Start
Okay
Exzellent
Dich hab ich schon im Chat
gesehen, ja
Die meisten eigentlich, die öfters da sind
sagen mir ein bisschen was
Also
das erste
wo ich dran denke
der Name sagt mir was, aber nichts
Gutes ist natürlich der Chainlore
Was auch immer
Ist der gar nicht, ne?
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, warum der überall gebannt ist
Vielleicht reicht er sich ja auch nur zusammen
Was hältst du eigentlich von Windows-Containern?
Ehrlich gesagt
Ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass es Windows-Container
überhaupt gibt
Sind das nicht unter
Ist Docker für Windows nicht eigentlich
auch nur ein Hyper-V-Frontend?
Oder?
Docker für Windows ist doch auch
nur Hyper-V
Der startet VMs
Und tut so als wärs Container
Bei dicker Desktop
Ja
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie das unter Windows
funktioniert. Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht
Warum ich Docker unter Windows
verwenden soll, wenn ich einfach Docker Unternehmung
verwenden kann und es da native ist und viel besser
funktioniert
Aber es gibt ja Leute, die sind
gezwungen Windows zu verwenden
Ich auf der Arbeit übrigens auch
Ich hab ja ein Windows-Only
Notebook
Zum Glück hab ich
Eine Linux-VM, auf der ich root bin und Internet-Access
und sonst alles
Ich hab mir jetzt ein KVM-Switch gekauft
Hab er noch nicht angeschlossen
Dass ich zwischen meinem Arbeitsnotebook
und meinem normalen Desktop besser umschalten kann
Weil es nervt mich teilweise
KVM-Switch, ja
Ja sowas, wo du
die Tastatur und die Maus und theoretisch auch
ein Bildschirm zwischen zwei verschiedenen Rechner umschalten kannst
Aber ich hab mir ein bisschen
besseren gekauft, der auch per Shortcut funktioniert
Da bin ich mal gespannt
Wie gut das
Das zeige ich euch, wenn ich das Ding
mal ausprobiert hab. Nicht, dass ich euch das jetzt
zeige und dann taugt das Ding nichts. Ich hab das Ding
Ich hab den KVM-Switch hier noch in der Packung liegen
Also der ist von
T-Smart
steht da drauf. T-Smart
To Enjoy Smart, das sind irgendwelche
China-Chinesen-Hersteller, keine Ahnung
Hab ich mir gekauft
Weil
Shortcut umschalten und
weil der irgendwie so einen Fast-Switch-Modus hat
Aber keine Ahnung
ob das Ding was taugt. Achso ja und uns, weil es
USB-C-Anschlüsse hat. Keine Ahnung
ob das was taugt
Muss ich erst ausprobieren
Automatischen für
Anime kann ich nicht machen, ich hab ja beides an. Außerdem brauch ich kein
Display umschalten, weil ich hab ein Monitor
für das Notebook und einen für meinen Desktop-Rechner
Ich weiß nicht
Ehrlich gesagt, also
Das ist echt eine Sache
die mir auf der neuen Arbeit mega auf den Sack geht
Dass die auf der einen Seite
mega bürokratisch sind bei vielen Sachen
Das ist aber noch nicht mal
das Nervigste, das hat ja noch durchaus
durchaus manchmal seine Vorteile
Aber
dass die so
mega restriktiv sind mit allem
ist total hängen geblieben. Ganz ehrlich
das 90%
von ihrem restriktiven Kram bräuchte man
überhaupt nicht, wenn man einfach ein Linux-Notebook
benutzen könnte. Die haben zum Beispiel
auf ihren Windows-Notebooks
es ist ohne Scheiß so, wenn ich
bei meinem Arbeits-Notebook
wenn ich dort hier unten ausklappe
Wenn ich dort hier unten ausklappe
Das ist ja noch Windows 10
Das geht bis hier. Das ist kein Spaß
Leute, das ist wirklich kein Witz
Die Anzahl der Icons geht bis hier
Die geht bis zu den anderen Icons
vor. So viel Scheiße läuft da im Hintergrund
Das ist wirklich kein Witz jetzt
50 Viren-Scanner
und Security-Shit
Und das bräuchtest du alles nicht, hätten die Leute
einfach ein Linux-Notebook. Die haben da auch
sowas, was beispielsweise nur
white-listet. Deswegen kann ich ja auch Windows nicht eins
drauf benutzen für irgendwas
Ich hab eigentlich Windows nur als Terminal offen
und bin auf meiner Linux-VM drauf
Die haben auch so Sachen, dass
das Software white-listed werden muss. Den ganzen
Mist bräuchtest du nicht. Gib es einfach Linux-Kleins
Das ist bei uns tatsächlich
auch so, witzigerweise
Ich hab auch schon mal versucht, das auszudricksen
Ich hab das mal versucht
auszudricksen und zwar
Ich hab mir gedacht
Ey, weißt du was?
Wenn
das Notebook per VPN auf die
Arbeit kommt, warum
logge ich mich nicht einfach irgendwie von
meiner Linux-VM auf den Notebook ein, vom Notebook
dann weiter? Die haben das
wirklich so gemacht
dass du
nur eine Netzwerkkarte aktiv haben kannst
und
wenn du VPN aufbaust, ist diese
Netzwerkkarte exklusiv für
VPN-Usage
reserviert. Was auch schon
ziemlich cack-weight ist
Also ich sehe da aktuell keine Möglichkeit
das irgendwie auszudricksen
Ja, das würde ich auch nehmen
Würde ich sofort nehmen
Du bräuchtest 90% dieser ganzen
Security-Sachen nicht
weil unter Linux hast du die
Probleme nicht. Ja, das wird bei uns nicht
funktionieren, weil Whitelisted-Sachen
hat
hat nicht
das aktuelle Surfacebook
sowohl LTE als auch
Touch als auch
Stiftbedienung
Also ich hatte auf der alten Arbeit
ein Surfacebook
das hatte Touch, das hatte glaube ich auch
eine SIM-Karte
Ob du den Bildschirm
drehen konntest, weiß ich nicht
Gibt's aber bestimmt
eine Surfacebook-Version mit dem drehbaren Bildschirm
Das ist auch
file-fat
Das ist eine coole Idee
Also ich hatte relativ lange ein Surfacebook
auf der alten Arbeit, aber tatsächlich
mit Linux drauf und das ging
ausgesprochen gut
Ich habe auch keine advanced Features
verwendet, also ich habe keine ansteckbare
Grafikkarte oder
Sleep
oder sonst was benutzt
So
Was haben wir denn hier Leute auf YouTube zu bieten
was wir uns angucken können
Nein
YouTube ist der Meinung
ich muss mir unbedingt
jedes Kack W
Video, was es nur gibt, anschauen
Oh das, das gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall
heute noch an, das gucke ich immer mega gerne
Home Automation
Beispiele, was die
Leute gebaut haben
Powerbanks, ein Einweg
Was? Powerbank aus
Einweg-Vapes
Das sind quasi
E-Zigaretten mit Akku oder wie?
Warum? Ich meine, man könnte
auch einfach, wenn man eine Powerbank braucht, sich eine Powerbank
holen, oder? Warum brauche
ich eine Powerbank
aus Einweg-E-Zigaretten
wenn ich einfach eine Powerbank mir holen kann
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als wäre
irgend so eine x-beliebige
Powerbank so wahnsinnig teuer
Ja, okay, das
interessiert mich aber tatsächlich jetzt, das müssen wir uns mal kurz
anschauen
Einweg-E-Zigaretten
Aber warum? Ich verstehe es nicht
E-Zigaretten, auch unter dem Markennamen
Ah, ist das, dass man die einsammeln kann und daraus
eine Powerbank bauen, oder was?
Vielleicht Recycling-mäßig
Das stimmt, das finde ich teilweise auch
ziemlich, ziemlich
nicht so pfeiffert von den Leuten
Wenn ich irgendwie über irgendwelche Felder
laufe, oder so auf Feldwegen
und so, sehe ich erstaunlich oft
irgendwelche Einweg-E-Zigaretten rumliegen
oder E-Zigaretten rumliegen
Und daraus
baue ich in diesem Video eine
wiederaufladbare Powerbank. Guck mal hier
Das ist ein ganzer Haufen leerer Einweg-E-Zigaretten
Einweg-E-Zigaretten, auch unter dem Markennamen
und daraus
baue ich in diesem Video
eine wiederaufladbare Powerbank
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, hä?
Einweg-E-Zigaretten, da sind wiederaufladbare
Akkus drin? Das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen Sinn
wenn man die nach dem Leerrauchen gar nicht mehr
benutzen kann. Ja, da habt ihr vollkommen recht
Das ist aber tatsächlich so
Warum, das klären wir auch in diesem Video
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt auch noch fragt
Nimm sie mit. Ne, ich laufe
doch nicht rum und sammle Dreck im Feld ein
Hä, aber
warum denn Einweg? Es gibt doch so
wiederaufladbare Dinger, wo man
Liquid reinfüllen kann. Ja, aber
diese Einweg-Elfbars, die sind
leider trotzdem ein Riesending
Ich hab hier in Hannover mal random
in 10 Kioske reingeguckt
und in jedem einzelnen... Warum?
Hat irgendjemand ne Ahnung, warum?
Warum Einweg-E-Zigaretten?
Ich mein, bei normalen Zigaretten versteh ich's
ja, die sind von Haus aus Einweg
Ja, aber
bei E-Zigaretten
Ich mein, so ne Zigarette ist danach halt
weg, bis auf diesen Stummel am Ende, aber
E-Zigaretten?
Geld? Meinst du, das ist wirklich billiger
Einweg, als sich so ein
auffüllbares Ding zu kaufen?
Ist das billiger, wirklich?
Und laut einer
Recherche von Tromatolix werden
davon allein in Deutschland... Ja gut, wenn es
bequemer ist, dann versteh ich das
Bequemlichkeit ist ja prinzipiell
der Hauptfaktor, warum man Leute dazu bekommt
seinen Service zu benutzen
Der Service
muss nicht sicher sein oder sonst was, der muss
einfach nur bequem sein, schon werden ihn die Leute benutzen
Millionenstück verkauft
und das ist nur die Aussage von
einem einzigen Distributor, es gibt noch
mehr davon. Ja, und die Teile werden
inzwischen sogar von deutschen Rappern wie
Haftbefehl, Samrack und... Wait a minute!
Haftbefehl hat ne eigene E-Zigarette?
...davon. Ja, und die Teile werden
inzwischen sogar von deutschen Rappern wie
Haftbefehl... Frankfurt,
Goethestraße, Louis Vuitton Store,
zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf
Sponsor. Moment!
Es gibt Haftbefehl Steve Jobs
E-Zigarette
Samrack und 187
Straßenbahnen vermarktet. Und in jedem
von diesen Dingern steckt ein
360 bis 700 mAh
Lithium-Ionen-Akku.
Akkus, die nicht dafür vorgesehen sind
wieder aufgeladen zu werden. Sondermüll
ist das, da steht auch drauf, seht ihr
an der durchgestrichenen Mülltonne da auf den Dingern
Man darf die Dinger auf gar keinen Fall
in den Hausmüll werfen. Deswegen werfen
die so viele Leute auch einfach auf irgendwelche Feldwege
Das ist ja kein Hausmüll.
Und was glaubt ihr? Gehen die Millionen
Einweg-Vapes in Deutschland alle in den
Sondermüll? Ganz, ganz sicher nicht.
Also wirklich ne totale Umweltsauerei
die, ist meine Meinung, schleunig
verboten werden sollte. So, aber
jetzt versuchen wir aus dem Dreck wenigstens
noch was Sinnvolles zu machen. Und was
machen wir jetzt mit der Powerbank? Ja, klar!
Ein Raspi 4 plus Display
mit Stromversorgung. Und damit spielen!
Quasi ein Einweg-Zigaretten-
Do-it-yourself-Steamdeck. Bleibt dran!
Liebe
Hackerinnen, liebe Internetsurfer, herzlich willkommen
hier bei
Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von Crowdsack. Ah, ich dachte jetzt
kommt NordVPN oder sowas wieder.
Das ist eine kollaborative
Open-Source-Sicherheits-Software,
die in der Lage ist, das Verhalten eurer
Website-Besucher zu analysieren.
Ehrlich gesagt, kenn ich nicht.
Kenn ihr das? Und auf alle
Arten von Angriffen entsprechend zu reagieren.
Ich glaub, ich hab da auf Reddit
schon mal Werbung für bekommen.
Das Ganze ist Crowdsourced,
das heißt, wenn eine IP-Adresse geblockt wird,
werden alle Community-Mitglieder darüber
informiert, sodass die die Adresse auch
blocken können. Crowdsourced?
Das heißt, der Inder, der Pfeifer-Inder
sitzt dann da dran und tippt das ein.
Crowdsack ist einfach zu installieren
und lässt sich dann über die Crowdsack-
Konsole steuern. Zurzeit wird das
kostenlose Cyber-Threat-Intelligence-Tool
in über 180 Ländern eingesetzt
und die Community hat bereits über
40 Millionen bösartige IPs angezeigt.
Crowdsack kann nicht nur Server
schützen, sondern natürlich auch VMs
oder Container. Guckt euch das nochmal an.
Die URL ist in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Erbung Ende.
Wir haben hier ne ganze Tüte voll
mit diesen Dingern und
Andrian natürlich. Andrian kennt sich
mit Löten aus, ich nicht so.
Und Andrian sagt, diese Schnapsidee
aus diesen Dingern ne
Powerbank zu machen, das geht irgendwie.
Aber ganz zuerst nochmal, warum
in aller Welt ist in diesen
Einweg-E-Zigaretten, warum machen
die da nicht ne AA-Batterie rein?
Also warum da wieder
aufladbarer Akku drin ist, das frage ich
mich tatsächlich auch.
Das sind bestimmt irgendwelche Regulatorien
oder so. Warum ist da so
ein teurer Akku drin? Also meine
naheliegendste Vermutung war, dass die Lithium-Akkus
verwenden, weil ich für diese
Heizspirale in diesen Einweg-Zigaretten
nen recht hohen Strom benötige.
Und sowas liefern diese kleinen Batterien
normalerweise nicht, sondern ich hab
hier eben ne Lithium-Batterie, die kann das
und natürlich kriegt man alles irgendwie mit ner gewissen
Leistung heiß, aber wenn ich da entsprechend viel Dampf
rauskriegen will, was ich ja haben will,
dann brauch ich schon so um die 10,
10-15 Watt, je nachdem. Hast du so ein Ding schon mal
aufgemacht? Ich hab so ein Ding schon mal aufgemacht, deswegen
hab ich ja schon ne Batterie in der Hand. Einfach so?
Einfach dran ziehen, genau. Boah, das ist krass,
das ist ja total einfach. So und dann hat man
hier so ein schwammartiges Material,
da ist wahrscheinlich... Das ist ja total einfach, na ja gut,
ich mein, dass die Dinger nicht die
beste Build-Quality haben als Einweg-Zigarette
ist doch klar. Die Nikotin-
Plöre reingetunkt. Genau, und dann
haben wir hier genau noch so einen Schwamm, der ist noch
davor. Und jetzt müssten wir gleich zum
Akku vordringen. Hey, gute Knepper-
X-Zange. Dieser Schwamm ist mit
Liquid getränkt. Genau, der ist
auch richtig nass. Das klebt ziemlich ekelhaft.
So, dann haben wir so ne Hülse
und jetzt kommt hier
Verdampfer. Ah ja, okay.
Genau.
Erstmal schön antatschen alles.
So ein totes
Insekt.
Wir haben das Ding jetzt auseinandergebaut, was ist denn das jetzt?
Also hier, das ist die Unterseite, ne?
Genau, das ist die Unterseite, die haben wir gerade mit dem Schraubendreher
rausgehauen. Meine Theorie ist,
wir haben das jetzt natürlich nicht verifiziert, dass hier ein
kleiner integrierter Schaltkreis drin ist
mit einem Druckschalter, der dann dafür
sorgt, dass am Ende
zu der Heizspirale,
zu dieser Glühwende durchgeschaltet wird,
dass dort also Hitze entsteht.
Also Druckschalter meinst du Unterdruck,
also wenn man saugt sozusagen. Genau, das merkst du ja auch, wenn du
daran saugst. Dann geht auch die LED an,
die da unten drin ist, ne? Die LED geht an,
du musst ein bisschen Kraft aufbringen,
damit das funktioniert.
Wenn man saugt, geht die LED an. Und dann schaltet der durch und wird hier
die Glühwende in diesem Liquid-Tank
erhitzen, sodass du dann
am Ende den Dampf da rauskriegst.
Ich hab so ein Ding ja gerade auseinandergebaut, weil es so
stinkt, dieses Liquid,
immer noch, zieh ich mir jetzt zumindest mal
Handschuhe an.
Es ist ja auch nicht wirklich dafür gedacht,
daran rumzuhantieren. Das ist echt eklig,
das klebt und es stinkt.
Du hast mir ja gerade schon erklärt, warum die wahrscheinlich
so einen umweltschädlichen Akku benutzen.
Wie ist das denn so deine
Einschätzung zu diesem Produkt?
Naja, also
wenn ich frei sprechen darf, dann
das ist eine riesige Umweltsauerei.
Also Lithium ist ja nicht pauschal
umweltschädlich, sondern nur wenn man
es zum Beispiel in solchen Konstellationen einfach
in den Restmüll wirft,
hinzukommt, ja oder auf irgendeinen
Waldweg wegschmeißt.
Wie gesagt, ich seh total oft solche Dinger
auf dem Feld liegen, auf dem Weg liegen.
Dass ja auch dieser Mantel,
dieses Gehäuse, was ja aus Metall ist,
dass das Ressourcen sind, die wir eigentlich
ganz dringend brauchen. Ich meine, aktuell ist es eh schon keine gute
Idee, im Sommer normale Zigaretten
wegzuschmeißen im Wald, gerade wenn es
trocken ist.
Da fackelt dir dann der Wald irgendwann ab.
E-Zigaretten
fackeln dir zwar nicht der Wald von ab, aber
es ist trotzdem keine gute Idee, die einfach
wegzuschmeißen.
Also es ist gar nicht förderlich, dass die so weggeworfen
werden. Was wir jetzt machen, wir bauen
jetzt aus den ganzen Dingern die Akkus
aus und dann versuchen wir dann eine Powerbank
mitzubauen, gucken, ob die wirklich nutzbar ist.
Das wäre mir viel zu anstrengend.
Ja, ich könnte sicherlich auch nach ein paar
Wochen, hätte ich genug zusammen, wenn ich die
sammeln würde. Weil wie gesagt, ich
seh öfters welche, da hätte ich bestimmt auch genug
zusammen, um eine Powerbank, aber das wäre mir ganz
ehrlich, das wäre mir der Stress.
Warte, was ist Stress?
Das ist ja eher so ein
Bastelprojekt, aber das wäre mir der Aufwand
nicht wert.
Und am Ende können wir dann zumindest
die Akkus dann in die
Batterieentsorgungskästen,
die in Supermärkten und so stehen,
tun. Genau, das ist ja auch das...
Wie lange brauche ich denn, um die Handschuhe anzuziehen?
Das Schlimme daran ist, es ist ja wirklich eine
Einmal-E-Zigarette.
Wer jetzt rauchen möchte, soll das meinetwegen tun.
Aber es gibt ja Alternativen,
wo ich zum Beispiel so eine
normale 18650 Lithiumzelle reintun kann.
Die kann ich austauschen, ist die Zelle kaputt,
tausche die Zelle aus, die E-Zigarette kaputt.
Es gibt auch solche... Jetzt hat er es aufgegeben
mit dem Handschuh.
Reicht jetzt. Wir halten genau dem Formfaktor.
Also das macht natürlich auch süchtig
wie Sau, also Nikotin, na klar.
Niemals kaufen, wenn ihr
sowas gerne benutzen wollt, dann kauft euch
was anderes. Wir wollen aber jetzt
einfach mal zeigen. Viele glauben das einfach.
Viele glauben das einfach gar nicht.
Leute, die Elfbars benutzen, dass das...
Guck mal, jetzt versteckt er schon die Hand mit dem Handschuh.
Das ist ein normaler Akku,
dass der da drin ist.
Ich habe tatsächlich Händler gefunden, die sowas verkaufen.
Ich habe nicht genau den gefunden mit den 360mAh.
Aber dadurch, dass das hier 3,7V
nominal sind, gehe ich davon aus,
das ist eine Lithiumzelle, die wir auflaufen.
3,7V haben die Dinge, aber glaube ich,
auch nur, wenn sie richtig voll sind.
Ich glaube, die gehen bis 4,2V.
Kann das sein? Weil ich habe mich
damit mal temporär
beschäftigt, als ich
in ESP32 mal
mit Akku betreiben wollte.
Ich glaube, die gehen maximal, wenn sie komplett
voll sind, rauf bis 4,2V.
Und ja,
dann am Ende haben sie so irgendwas
2,8V oder sowas.
Also sprich,
du kannst damit
einen ESP32
ganz gut betreiben,
ohne irgendwelche Regelungen
dazwischen.
Wenn der halbwegs
gescheit gemacht ist.
Und wir löten das jetzt einfach mal zusammen
und haben hier so eine Powerbank-Platine
und versuchen das dann mal aufzuladen.
Und die Powerbank-Platine, was macht die?
Das ist ein stinknormaler Laderegler,
der einerseits eine kontrollierte
Ladung für Lithium-Akkus liefert.
Das heißt, ich schließe hier zum Beispiel,
also im Normalfall wäre das dann zum Beispiel
so ein 10-Ampere-Stunden-Block.
Die löte ich hier ganz normal an
und dann kann ich hier per Micro-USB anschließen,
das aufladen und die Power dann wieder raus.
Genau, so einen Teil habe ich auch,
wenn man sich ein Low-Power-ESP32-Board
kauft, zum Beispiel sowas,
dann haben die
so eine Ladeschaltung
schon mit on-board.
Zum Beispiel der hier, das Ding ist richtig nice,
wenn man Low-Power-Projekte basteln möchte
auf der ESP32-Basis,
die Dinger
verbrauchen fast nichts im Deep-Sleep,
also die Boards.
Der D-Bond-Mini
beispielsweise auch sehr beliebt ist,
der verbraucht viel zu viel im Sleep.
Und die haben unten,
haben die sogar hier einen extra Anschluss für den Akku
und Lade-Elektronik
mit drin.
Und hier kann man auch theoretisch einen Akku anlöten.
Und das Ding
sorgt dafür, dass das Teil nicht überladen wird
und uns um die Ohren fliegt sozusagen.
Und dein Plan ist jetzt,
aus den E-Zigaretten
die Akkus raus zu bröseln
und die dann einfach in Reihe
an die beiden Drähte dran zu löten
sozusagen. Parallel, weil wenn wir
die in Reihe schalten würden, dann wäre die Gefahr
wir überladen es doch relativ hoch.
Und dadurch, dass wir hier schon 3,7...
Moment, Chat, Chat, Elektronik-Kurs
jetzt im Chat.
Wenn man die in Reihe aneinander lötet,
heißt das, oder so in Serie
heißt das nicht. Heißt das nicht in Serie?
Oder was auch immer. Wären dann nicht auch
die Spannung,
müsste man dann nicht auch die Spannung zusammen
zählen? Also wären das
dann nicht, keine Ahnung,
3,5 Volt plus 3,5
oder 7 Volt und am Ende würde das Ding einfach kaputt gehen?
Wohin ging parallel
die Spannung gleich bleibt?
Ja, ne?
Ich erinnere mich da dunkel.
7 Volt haben, schalten wir die jetzt einfach
alle parallel. Du baust die auseinander, ich löte
eine Runde und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Und was andersrum? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Und was wäre jetzt genau die Gefahr, wenn wir die in Reihe schalten würden?
Da ist die Gefahr, dass
möglicherweise einzelne Zellen
langsamer anders geladen werden
müssen. Und wenn ich dann einfach weiter
von außen Strom hinzugebe
und einfach versuche, die Ladeschlussspannung
zu erreichen, dann kann es passieren, dass einzelne Zellen
überladen werden, während andere noch gar nicht
fertig sind. Ja, Lithium-Akkus zu überladen
kann unterschiedliche Effekte haben.
Von irgendwelchen Schutzschaltungen, die abschalten
bis hin ins Fakten. Die gehen in Flammen
auf oder gasen aus, je nachdem.
Das zeigen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz, was
eigentlich passiert, wenn man so ein Teil
kurz schließt. Nur mal so kurz als
Warnung, dass ihr Bescheid wisst.
Ja, und weiter?
Ja, jetzt
übertreibt halt. Man sieht halt zwei
Batterien ein bisschen brennen.
Und bei der Musik
denkst du, ach nee, gleich
explodieren sie vielleicht noch.
Ja, übertreibt.
Dann starten wir mal.
Nicht wirklich viel passiert.
Schön bunt.
Oh, Banane.
Ja, also der Fachlöter
Andrian hat jetzt 23...
Ich glaube, das würden
wir auch hinkriegen, ohne Fachlöter zu sein.
Von den Dingern da aufgelötet.
Ich glaube, das reicht erstmal für unser Experiment.
Und das sieht wunderbar aus.
Das sieht richtig aus wie Fluxkompensator.
Als könnte man damit irgendwie in die
Zukunft reisen oder so.
Also wir haben jetzt hier diesen Controller
und da schließen wir Mikro-USB-Kabeln an.
Genau, ich löte das jetzt gleich noch da an
und dann schließen wir das
an, zusammen mit dem USB-Messgerät.
Und dann können wir auch gleich gucken, ob das lädt.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Und in diesem
aufregenden Moment nochmal einmal der Disclaimer.
Macht das nicht zu Hause nach.
Wir haben das jetzt gerade hier noch so ein bisschen
zusammengefrickelt, um euch das mal zu zeigen.
Die sind auflautbar, das ist Energie.
Wir wissen nicht genau, von welchem
Hersteller die sind.
Sag mal Leute, von der Farbe her.
Ist das eine Wellalötstation?
So von der Farbe her
sieht das irgendwie ein bisschen so aus.
Haben die nicht so dieses
hellblau?
Das sind die Dinger, die
ultra teuer sind.
Um zu zeigen, die sind auflautbar, das ist Energie.
Wir wissen nicht genau,
von welchem Hersteller die sind.
Es kann sein, dass die wirklich nur für einmalige,
zweimalige, dreimalige Nutzung geeignet sind.
Es besteht Brandgefahr.
Tut's lieber nicht.
So, ich steck das da jetzt rein.
Ja, steck das da mal rein und dann gucken wir, was passiert.
Das ist aufregend.
Ja, aufregend.
Es lädt.
Jetzt blinkt das.
Das bedeutet wahrscheinlich, dass es lädt.
Und da gehen 5 Volt
0,7 Ampere
durch. Genau, also wir laden jetzt
hier gerade mit
4 Watt laden wir gerade.
Wir warten jetzt, bis der Rotz aufgeladen ist
und dann schließen wir da mal irgendwas an diese
Powerbank an.
Gucken, wie lange wir da irgendwas mit betreiben
können. Ja genau, wir schauen einfach mal,
wie viele Wattstunden wir jetzt noch rauskriegen.
Also du meinst, die anderen
sind auch teuer, aber taugen nix.
Also ich habe nicht vor mir
eine neue Lötstation zu kaufen. Ich habe aber auch
keine von Vella. Ich habe eine von
Ezra oder so?
Äh...
Ersa.
Ich muss gerade mal kurz drauf gucken.
Ist das nicht China-Chinesen-Kram?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Das sieht
sehr ähnlich zu dem aus,
was ich habe.
Das ist das Teil.
Also was ich an der mag, ist halt
erstens austauschbare Spitze
und was ich
cool finde, dass
der... mal kurz zeigen.
Ja, hier
sieht man es halbwegs. Was ich cool finde, dass
die so ein flexibles
Kabel haben. Also du merkst
eigentlich gar nicht...
Der Lötkolben ist sehr leicht und du hast ein flexibles
Kabel. Also es kommt dir nicht in die Quere.
Und ja,
du kannst das Ding irgendwo nebenhin stellen und brauchst
eigentlich nur das hier auf dem Tisch. Das ist eigentlich echt gut durchdacht.
Agiles Kabel.
Ob die überhaupt tatsächlich aufladbar war?
Noch brennt nichts, noch
gast nichts aus.
Ja, wir haben jetzt
unsere Elfpaar-Powerbank
geladen. Wir wollten sie eigentlich über Nacht
laden lassen, aber als ich
dann nach Hause gefahren bin, habe ich eine kleine Panikanfrage
gekriegt und dachte, ich facke den ganzen
Verlag ab und dann haben wir das doch nicht
über Nacht laufen lassen. Das heißt, die Akkus...
Ja, so selbst gebasteltes Zeug
ist immer keine allzu schlaue Idee über Nacht,
ohne dass irgendjemand da ist.
Sind jetzt so vier Stunden, würde ich sagen. Unbeaufsichtig zu laden.
Vier, fünf, sechs Stunden und jetzt sind sie glaube ich halb voll.
Es reicht ja, um auszuprobieren.
Und ich habe hier meine
tolle Raspi-Installation. Das ist ein
Raspi 4 mit so einem kleinen Display.
Display habe ich jetzt im Moment noch normal am Strom
hängen, weil das die Powerbank
eventuell... Ja, Patrick, hat er bei mir auch.
Ich weiß nicht, warum. Wenn ich es schaffe, das probieren wir gleich nochmal aus.
Aber der Raspi, der wird
jetzt komplett von den
E-Zigaretten-Akkus gepowert.
Hoffe ich. Und das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Leider verbrauchen
Raspberry Pi ein bisschen zu viel, dass ich das
praktikabel an der Batterie
betreiben lässt.
Also ich hatte es mal ausgerechnet.
Ich glaube, an so einer
normalen 0,15 Powerbank
läuft ein Raspberry Pi
eidel, glaube ich, fünf, sechs Stunden.
Soll ich?
Ja, hör mal.
Da kommen ganz normal fünf Volt raus,
wenn man sie einschaltet.
Okay. Ja, tatsächlich.
Die Raspi-LED ist an.
Der zielt ungefähr
fünf an.
Das Display geht an. Krass.
Naja, es wundert mich nicht.
Ich meine, es ist
kein großer Unterschied zu
irgendeinem normalen
Powerbank.
Die Dinger sehen innen ähnlich aus.
Fünf Volt, 1,1 Ampere.
Oh.
Ist das eine Fehlermeldung?
Under Voltage detected.
Okay, das ist aber vielleicht nicht so schlimm.
Könnte sein, dass er trotzdem bootet.
Ja, das Ding bootet.
Aber wahrscheinlich kann es sein, wenn du es ordentlich
belastest, dass er den dann abkackt.
Das ist ja überraschend.
Muss doch nicht mal so sein.
Was mit Rauchen zu tun hat.
Er taktet sich dann vielleicht runter oder so.
Das hat mit dem Bier trinken zu tun.
Jetzt versuche ich auch noch
das Display... Okay, easy.
Wir wissen, dass man aus
Wegwerf-Akkus eine Powerbank
bauen kann. Gut.
Das habe ich mir vorher auch schon gedacht.
Was mich nur tatsächlich auch gewundert hat, ist, dass
da wiederaufladbare Akkus drin sind.
... und aus mobiles Gaming
sind.
... wirklich aufentsorgen.
Wir haben ja nicht herausgefunden,
wer eigentlich...
Das ist jetzt nicht so spannend.
Okay.
Warum soll ich mir jetzt
Regeln für japanische Schulen
angucken?
Nicht so, als würde ich demnächst in Japan
in Schule gehen. Aber es scheinen viele zu interessieren.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die machen komische Sachen.
Microservices.
Ich glaube, das Video kenne ich.
Ja, ja, das kenne ich.
Das ist das, wo er jetzt an der Tafel
gleich seine 100.000 Microservices
erklärt und dass der eine auf den
anderen zugreifen muss, dass er sich zum
authentifizieren und sowas...
...
Mann, mach halt mal Update.
Was braucht der denn da so lange schon wieder?
Was ist denn das?
Oh, er muss irgendwas zippen.
Alles klar, na gut, dann zippe mal.
Jetzt ist er fertig gezippt.
Auf, hopp hopp, ich will einfach nur
rebooten.
Ich hab zu viele
Icons installiert.
Das dauert drei Stunden.
Warum hab ich eigentlich so viele Icons
installiert? Ist das nicht so, als bräuchte ich
bei mir im Terminal oder im Browser sonderlich viele
Icons? Warum hab ich
überhaupt irgendwelche Iconpacks
installiert? Ich benutze nirgendwo
doch,
in meinem FileExpress ist das Einzige, wo ich
Icons verwende. So,
Betriebssystem, Icons.
Oh nein, Passwort-Leak, Leute.
Haben wir es jetzt?
Braille? Ist es fertig?
Okay, wir haben es geschafft.
Das ist too nah,
ist das als FileManager gewesen.
Aber ich benutze den eigentlich nie.
Ich benutze den nur, wenn man einen GUI-FileManager
braucht, nämlich
zum rauskopieren
aus der VM.
Das muss man irgendwie mit dem GUI-FileManager machen,
weil das sonst VMware nicht checkt.
Reinkopieren in die VM kannst du
auch über das Terminal, aber rauskopieren
kannst du nur gescheit mit dem GUI-FileManager.
Also guck, kannst ja zum Beispiel,
zeig dir das, ja,
ist Passwort-Leak, Leute.
Nicht verraten, okay.
Also wenn ich jetzt
zum Beispiel hier was rauskopieren will
aus der VM,
dann geht das nur, wenn ich das über,
na super,
dann geht das nur, wenn ich das hier drüber mache.
Ihr versteht, ja?
Und ich weiß nicht, wow, was ist denn hier los?
Und ich weiß nicht so genau, warum das ist,
aber okay, man muss halt
irgendwie tracken und droppen, dass es funktioniert.
Best-Practice-Passwort,
würde ich sagen.
Das ist eines der weitverbreitetsten
Passwörter weltweit, das kann nicht schlecht sein,
sonst würden es nicht so viele benutzen.
Boah, 44 Minuten, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Ja,
das wollte ich mir angucken, genau.
Menschen, Tiere,
Automationen.
Vermutlich super out of context, aber ich
überlege mir C++...
Der Satz, der so schon anfängt, der ist schon...
No,
God! Okay, lesen wir mal weiter.
Vermutlich so, aber ich überlege
mir C++ für die Unreal Engine. Ja, okay,
Unreal hast ja keine andere Möglichkeit,
wenn du an Unreal
in Reihen rumbasteln möchtest.
Was denkst du, wie viel Zeit dies in Anspruch nehmen würde?
Also, C++ ordentlich zu
lernen, ist eine Lebensaufgabe.
Allerdings,
im Kontext von Unreal,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, davon, ne?
Also, kann ich gar
keine Zeit...
Ich mach selbst keine Spieleentwicklung,
noch kenne ich mich mit Unreal aus.
Aber ich denke mal, für den Kontext
von Unreal sollte C++
wahrscheinlich halbwegs machbar
sein, weil die wahrscheinlich, das rate ich
jetzt einfach mal, nicht, dass ich davon
großartig Ahnung hätte, wahrscheinlich
nicht den ganzen
Shit verwenden, den C++
eigentlich noch so bietet, sondern
sie werden wahrscheinlich das benutzen, was sie selbst für sinnig
halten und den anderen Krams einfach links
liegen lassen. Also dürfte das
wahrscheinlich durchaus machbar sein.
Das Problem ist wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr,
dass C++ lernen für Unreal, sondern
Unreal lernen. Ich weiß nicht,
gibt es mittlerweile auch Möglichkeiten, Unreal
mit was anderem zu programmieren als
C++? Ich mein, ja, man kann diese
Blueprint-Editor-Geschichte
benutzen, aber dann muss das da alles
GUI-mäßig sein. Gibt es
nicht auch vielleicht
Javascript?
Zum Teufel.
Ich glaub, alter,
ich glaub, mein Windows hat grade Updates
gemacht. Auf dem
zweiten Rechner. Einfach mal random
Updates durchgeführt.
Warum macht es denn so
was? Geht mir schon
ein wenig auf den Keks.
War da nicht was mit Javascript?
Doch, kann schon sein.
Was für YouTube-Videos schaust du privat eigentlich
ohne Stream? Muss ich
aufs Handy gucken, alle möglichen Sachen.
Ähm, guck jetzt einfach
meine Watch-History.
Also hauptsächlich Technik-Kram
und
Sachen, wo man gut bei schlafen kann.
Also was ich,
ein Channel, den ich gerne gucke, den wir aber
hier im Stream relativ selten
gucken, ist
den hier, den gucke ich recht gerne.
Vor allem, weil der oftmals
so Oldschool-Shit hat, ja.
Wie zum Beispiel sowas hier.
Irgendwelche beschriftbaren
CD-Dinger. Der hat oftmals richtig
Oldschool-Kram. Was ich von dem auch gerne gucke,
ist, wir bauen
an uns den Traumrechner von 1998
und sowas. Aber
das ist halt, weil ich Boomer
bin, ja.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das denn
für eine Ausgeburt der Hölle,
Alter? Was hat er da am Start?
Windows
Vista Build.
Es gibt wirklich Leute, also
bei ihm frage ich mich halt immer, was der am
Ende macht.
Mit dem Zeug, ne.
Was das da oben rechts für ein Controller ist?
Gute Frage.
Chat, ich muss mal meinen Stream-Vorschau-Rechner
kurz starten.
Der macht komische Dinger.
Der hat, glaube ich, gerade einen Grafikkartentreiber-Update
im Hintergrund gemacht und
macht jetzt
komische Dinge. Ich muss meinen Vorschau-Rechner
mal kurz neu starten. Das heißt, ich muss hier
in den Chat gegucken.
Winamp. Ja, Winamp ist eh das Beste.
Winamp.
Wie geht das?
Lama's Ass? Ne, wie geht
dieser Winamp-Spruch?
Long? Lama? Irgendwas mit Lama.
Ich meine,
das Ding ist schon übertrieben.
So, ich muss mal kurz die Tastatur
umstapseln.
Blum, blum, blum, blum.
Blum, blum, blum.
Winamp kicks the Lama's Ass.
Irgendwie sowas. Genau, ja.
Irgendwie sowas.
Name geändert. Aha.
Ich hätte es mir fast schon gedacht.
So, ich muss mal kurz den
Vorschau-Rechner wieder einschalten.
So.
Zack, zack.
Gut. Wunderbar.
Exzellent.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz pinkeln.
Danach gucken wir uns hier weiter an.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Pipo Toilet Zoom.
Geht schnell.
So, wieder am Start.
Weiter geht's.
Eure Smart-Home-Beispiele.
Menschen, Tiere, Automation.
Ja, die Videos gucke ich immer gern.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Das letzte Mal, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
war ja da was richtig Abgedrehtes dabei,
was ich mega nice fand, aber so nie bauen würde.
Und zwar, genau das hier.
Das hier.
Das letzte Mal hat er doch den...
Moment, wo ist der Rasenmäher?
Hier.
Der Rasenmäher, der aus diesem...
Das fand ich mega nice gemacht.
Auch wenn ich's mir im Leben nicht selbst
in den Garten bauen würde, mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Das ist mir viel zu aufwendig.
Und die Mähroboter funktionieren eh nicht richtig
bei mir im Garten, dank der ganzen Baumwurzeln
und sowas.
Das fand ich...
Das fand ich ne richtig coole Sache.
Jetzt fährt er wieder runter.
Genau.
Das fand ich schon cool gemacht.
Das ist natürlich schon eigentlich
ne sehr elegante Geschichte.
Ja, das fand ich cool.
So, mal schauen, was es heute gibt.
Was wir in unseren Wohnungen und Häusern
und vor allem Gärten alles automatisieren können.
Wir gucken, was ihr so im Garten macht.
Was sich sonst so für den Urlaub automatisieren lässt,
denn das ist heute die Urlaubsfolge.
Ihr seht es an meinem Outfit und ich würde
sagen, ich mach sogar noch einen Knopf auf.
Oder auch nicht.
Vor allem nutze ich natürlich eure Einsendung,
um dieses Video voll zu bekommen, damit ich es
veröffentlichen kann, wenn ich vielleicht mal
im Urlaub die Füße hochlegen möchte.
Es ist quasi eine doppelte Urlaubsfolge.
Oder so.
Vom Wasserfass über alternative Bewässerungen
zu Hasen- und Paketkästen.
Und jede gezeigte Automation bekommt wie immer
einen Amazon-Gutschein im Wert von 50 Euro.
Und ich kann eine Woche vorarbeiten,
weil ich einfach eure Arbeit nutze.
Menschen, Tiere, Automation, Ausgabe 20.
Los geht's mit Dennis.
Und der hat uns eine Gartenbewässerung
und Automation geschickt.
Was gibt es mehr für den Urlaub geeignetes,
als das?
Wasser kommt ja zur Zeit nicht mehr genügend vom Himmel.
Also hab ich einen Brunnen gebohrt und hol es aus der Erde.
Den denn noch nicht fertigen.
Einfach mal einen Brunnen gebohrt. Easy.
Ja, macht man ja mal so nebenbei.
Im Brunnenstube befindet sich
ein Gardena-Hauswasserautomat,
der im Standby läuft.
Brunnenstube? Ist das das Wort, das ich hätte googeln müssen,
um rauszufinden?
Also ich geh davon aus, der Typ weiß,
was er macht, weil sonst wüsste er nicht,
dass das Brunnenstube heißt.
Hat das Wort von euch jemals schon jemand gehört?
...fertig zu kaufen gibt.
Und sobald Wasser gefordert wird,
springt dieser um
und fängt an zu pumpen,
also fördert Wasser aus dem Brunnen nach oben.
Die Pumpe ist mittlerweile bei mir seit über drei Jahren
im Einsatz und wirklich ein gutes Teil,
sofern man dran denkt, die im Winter auch reinzuholen
und somit vor Frost zu schützen.
Was soll das denn jetzt? Ist das eine Spitze gegen mich?
Nur weil ich das vielleicht im letzten Jahr
nicht ganz gemacht habe und die vielleicht
erst beim zweiten Frost reingeholt habe?
Das ist übertreib halt, wa?
Hier sind wir jetzt beim Herzstück meiner Automation angelangt
und zwar einem Hunter Magnetventil.
Das wird wiederum über
einen Shelly 1 gesteuert.
Da der Brunnen aktuell leider noch nicht tief genug
gebohrt ist, liefert er nur
150 bis 170 Liter Wasser
und es dauert zwei Stunden etwa,
bis er wieder vollgelaufen ist und ich wieder
Wasser entnehmen kann. Sobald das Magnetventil
öffnet, wird das
Brunnenwasser durch den Hauswasserautomat
hochgepumpt und in
drei IBC-Containern, also insgesamt
3000 Litern gespeichert.
In der Shelly-App habe ich hierfür...
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich, warum der das gemacht hat.
Das...
Okay, das schaltet
ein, pumpt das Wasser
raus, dann schaltet's aus,
wartet zwei Stunden, bis das wieder nachgelaufen
ist und dann...
Ah ja, okay, das macht tatsächlich Sinn.
...für eine Automation erstellt,
die das Hunter... Der Beregnungskreis!
3000 Liter
gespeichert.
In der Shelly-App habe ich hierfür eine Automation...
Boah, der Beregnungskreis.
...erstellt, die das Hunter Magnetventil
für jeweils zehn Minuten öffnet,
das Ganze alle drei Stunden,
also insgesamt acht Zyklen pro Tag
und pro Zyklus kann ich 120
bis 150 Liter Wasser entnehmen,
komme dann in drei Tagen
auf etwa 3000 Liter.
Darf man in seinem Garten eigentlich
überhaupt einen Brunnen bohren?
Ich meine,
man muss jetzt nicht pipsicher sein als der Papst,
ich habe damit keine Schmerzen, wenn das Leute
machen. Ich frage mich nur, ob man...
Wir haben doch in Deutschland garantiert alles geregelt
in der Richtung. Wahrscheinlich darf
man das gar nicht. Also wir haben
auch einen Brunnen im Garten, aber den
hat mein Opa selbst gebaut vor...
Also Brunnen, Brunnen
ist gut. Das ist ein Rohr mit
Pumpe dran, ja.
Und das hat er selbst gebaut vor
Ewigkeiten, ja.
Mein Opa hat generell relativ viel selbst gebaut.
Ihr kennt ja noch den Fahrstuhl.
Fivehead-Fahrstuhl.
Und da funktioniert heute noch der Brunnen.
Manchmal ist er ein bisschen
zu
geschlammt oder so,
dann funktioniert er nicht richtig.
Um ein versehentliches Überlaufen der Tanks
zu verhindern, befindet sich in einem der
Tanks ein Schwimmerschalter,
der bei maximaler Füllung
die Verbindung zwischen Shelly
und Magnetventil kappt.
Solange der Brunnen nicht durchgängig Wasser liefert
oder es wieder mehr regnet,
war das für mich eine relativ einfache Variante,
um auch in längeren Hitzeperioden
den Garten mit genügend Wasser zu versorgen.
Das, was du gemacht hast, ist ja ganz cool.
Und von der Idee ganz interessant
auch für mich, weil ich ja in Zukunft
von meinem unendlichen
Grundwasserbrunnen offenbar
auf einen Zisternen-Lifestyle umstellen
werde oder müssen werde.
Und das erfordert
ja ein bisschen Umdenken und du scheinst ja auch
deinen nicht ganz so
tiefen Brunnen zu nutzen, um
quasi deinen Puffer voll zu machen.
Jetzt wäre natürlich ganz spannend zu wissen,
wie viel du so für
einen Tag Bewässerung brauchst,
wenn du jetzt 3000 Liter da hast.
Aber das ist vielleicht auch nur, weil ich das
nicht so richtig einschätzen kann.
Und du trennst die Verbindung
vom Shelly zum Ventil. Das heißt, du brauchst
nochmal irgendwie einen Haktor dazwischen,
wenn ich deine Aussage gerade
richtig verstanden habe. Also das ist deine Methode,
um dich vor dem Überlaufen zu schützen.
Ja gut, das ist vielleicht die solidere Trennung.
Also du könntest natürlich auch
statt die Automation,
wann das läuft, in
der Shelly-App zu planen,
das Ganze in irgendwas dynamischeren
machen, Home Assistant
zum Beispiel.
Und dann einfach die Automation
an den Tagen aussetzen
oder dem Shelly den Impuls geben,
sobald der letzte Tag voll ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist
es Geschmackssache, was dem übel ist.
Eigentlich, wenn man nur das hat,
finde ich das eine super Sache, das über die Shelly-App
zu machen. Da brauchst du keinen Home Assistant
oder irgendwie über andere Sachen Gedanken machen.
Einfach Shelly, Shelly-App, fertig, aus.
Wenn das das Einzige ist, was man hat,
lohnt sich das gar nicht so sehr, dann noch was drumherum zu bauen.
Sobald man noch andere Sachen
hat, ja, dann ist sowas wie Home Assistant
sicherlich sinnvoll. Habe ich auch am Start.
Weniger Aktoren
und ein bisschen mehr Software oder ein bisschen
weniger Software und dafür
ist hart vorbei,
weil es dann keine Verbindung mehr zum Ventil gibt.
So, der Green hat mir Alexa
für seine Motormarkise geschickt.
Hallo Andreas, wir haben hier auf unserem
Balkon diese Markise,
die lässt sich mit so einem Garagentoröffner
ausfahren. Ist das nicht ein
Markisentoröffner? Ziemlich lang.
Geht das, eine ganze Nummer?
Angeber. Und auch wieder
anhalten und auch wieder einfahren.
Ganz einfache
Sache.
Ich kann folgen. Das Problem an dem Ding
ist, dass es natürlich nur diese eine
Fernbedienung gibt und sie liegt
mal unterm Sofa. Natürlich.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding, wo wahrscheinlich der Hersteller genau
guckt, dass man das nicht einfach mit irgendwas
anderem ansteuern kann.
Deswegen habe ich mir folgende Lösung überlegt.
Die Fernbedienung hier sendet
auf 433 Megahertz.
Ich habe ungefähr mit dieser Konstruktion,
das ist so ein Arduino-Bastelkit,
433 Megahertz. Hat er
die Antenne selbst gedreht?
Ist das eine
genau auf die Frequenz
abgestimmte Antenne, die du da hingewickelt
hast? Also es gibt ja fertige
433 Megahertz-Module.
Da muss man keine Antenne mehr selbst
drehen. Mit Strom
habe ich noch dran gemacht.
Einfach das Signal als Audio
abgehört.
Was?
Ich habe mir das mit Audacity angeschaut.
Was hast du?
Wie die einzelnen
Bits aussehen. Ach so.
Okay.
Der hat quasi
so eine Art
Oszilloskop gemacht mit Audacity.
Aussehen.
Und das dann mit dem Arduino auf einen
ESP8266
mit dieser Voxmo Library
als Alexa-Switch eingerichtet.
Und tatsächlich hängt jetzt einfach hier
ein ESP8266
mit diesem
433 Megahertz-Modul. Der hat quasi das Signal
mitgeschnitten und
sich angeguckt, was da übertragen wird
und hat das dann quasi nachgebaut.
433 Megahertz-Sender und Antenne.
Einfach lustig im Raum.
Also der hat sich das Signal
angeguckt und hat dann eine Firmware
programmiert für seinen ESP,
der quasi exakt das gleiche sendet.
Ja, eigentlich eine gute Sache.
Das kann man vielleicht auch nochmal
schön machen.
Das kann man
schön machen bedeutet, es bleibt für immer so hängen.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Alexa wäre
der Part, den ich
dabei nicht bräuchte.
Ich würde das wahrscheinlich über
Smartphone steuern. Aber gut.
Oder ich würde es automatisch
ausfahren lassen anhand des Sonnenstandes
oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber wenn man Alexa eh bei sich hat
und das gut findet, why not?
Computer, Markise aus.
Genau, und das Ganze
kann jetzt natürlich auch hier über
meinen Home Assistant abhängig von der
Helligkeit und Tageszeit gesteuert werden
mit anderen Sensoren,
dass die Markise bei Regen auch vorher einfährt.
So ist es mir egal, wo die
Fernbedienung gerade rum liegt.
Ich kann es ja immer per Stimme steuern.
Ich weiß nicht wieso, aber die Umwandlung
der Impulse in Audiosignale,
wenn du das enginierst, um sie
dann wieder selbst zurückzugeben,
macht irgendwie, dass ich mich
unwohl fühle bei der ganzen Nummer.
Warum? Ich meine, das Ergebnis ist cool.
Hä, wieso?
Das ist das, was du quasi mit dem
Oszilloskop auch machst, wenn du halt direkt
an die Schaltung irgendwie drankommst
und guckst, was dazu übertragen wird.
Oder mit irgendeinem
Logic Analyzer oder sowas. Nur, dass er halt,
weil es Funk ist,
mitgeschnitten hat und sich dann in Audacity
das ergibt schon irgendwo Sinn.
Auch wenn es extrem pfeifert ist, auf die Idee wäre ich
nicht gekommen. Das ist quasi
ein 433 MHz
Netzwerksniffer, ja.
Das funktioniert offensichtlich.
Wobei das besser
geht, es gibt ja solche
wie heißt das
SDR
Sticks oder sowas?
Nicht Stocks, Sticks.
Sowas.
Es gibt ja so Sticks, 433 und
800 irgendwas Megahertz.
Da kann man sowas ganz gut,
ja sowas hier in der Richtung, genau.
Da kann man sowas ganz gut mitschneiden.
Und dann muss man
das nicht über Audio und so
machen. Aber ja, ist
eine gute Idee. Du hast dir das da so
hingebaut, wie du das haben
wolltest. Hattest ein schönes Projekt
dabei. Vielleicht kannst du da tatsächlich
sogar noch ein bisschen auf der Home Assistant Ebene
abfangen, dass du jetzt...
Ja, so ein Stick habe ich mir auch mal gekauft, um hier
zu analysieren, was dann überall so
verschickt wird. Und es ist mehr als man denkt.
Das sind Wetterstationen, Temperatursensoren
und sowas. Kann man alles abfangen?
Abfangen ist das falsche Wort.
Man fängt ja nichts ab. Mitschneiden.
Wieder reinfahren, unterschiedliche
Befehle geben kannst.
Also gerade jetzt mit den neuen Sprachassistenten
auf Home Assistant Ebene. Aber...
Ich meine, ich habe ja seit einem Jahr
oder so, habe ich ja auch so eine China-Chinesen
Wetterstation im Hof.
Und die überträgt auch paar
33 Mhz.
Konnte man damit alles abfangen?
Es ist schon gut, auf der Terrasse die Sonne genießen zu können
im Urlaub und im Zweifel
per Sprache zu beenden,
wenn es genug Sonne war.
Oder sie reinzufahren, wenn du das
vergessen hast.
Und diese ganzen smarten Funktionen jetzt auch für
ein etwas älteres Varema-Modell
nachzurüsten, finde ich super.
Ich war ja hier in der komfortablen Situation, das
mit Varema zusammen machen zu können
und auch für eine etwas neuere Markise.
Hier das Video, falls
sich das jemand anschauen möchte.
Markisensponsoring.
POG.
Joe hat ein smartes Wasserfass.
Pumpe einschalten.
Das Wasserfass sah jetzt auf den ersten Blick
nicht so smart aus.
Da läuft Wasser raus.
Pumpe einschalten.
Ah, so eine ganz normale
WiFi-Steckdose.
Was ist denn das
für eine Konstruktion?
Was ist das?
Das ist ja...
Das sieht extrem
WiFi-Fat aus.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist ein Fensterkontakt.
Jetzt erkenne ich das.
Jetzt checke ich das.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich
schönere Möglichkeiten, aber die Idee ist gut.
Leute, ich glaube, ich habe es erkannt.
Guckt mal.
Das ist eine Flasche, die dadurch,
dass das Wasser steigt,
nach oben mitsteigt.
Das hier ist ein Fensterkontakt.
Hier ist der Magnet und hier ist der Fensterkontakt.
Jetzt schließt der Fensterkontakt
und dann kriegt er die Nachricht,
Fass ist voll.
Die Idee ist megacool,
aber ich fürchte,
nicht sonderlich langlebig.
Die Idee ist aber schon geil.
Jetzt geht es aus.
Ist das eine Mausefalle?
Das ist ein Fenstersensor.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Ich glaube aber, dass das nicht länger
als ein paar Wochen hält.
Mit einem Fensterkontakt?
Hat er einen Fensterkontakt zusammengeschoben?
Ja, richtig.
Das ist auch eine Maschine
mit einem Türsensor.
Das ist richtig Next-Level-Bastelstelz.
Das ist ganz fantastisch.
Wir sehen hier
eine Klemme.
Das ist mit Heißkleber.
Hat er das hier dran gepappt?
Nein, das wird nicht lange halten.
Das ist ein schöner Proof-of-Concept.
Das müsste man irgendwie anders bauen.
Es gibt ja mehrere Möglichkeiten,
wie man das machen könnte.
Zwei Sachen, die mir sofort einfallen.
Das erste ist ein Ultraschallsensor.
Mit dem Ultraschallsensor
kann man ganz gut erkennen,
wie voll der Stand der Tonne ist.
Man könnte auch einfach
einen Feuchtigkeitssensor nehmen
und den hier oben an den Rand pappen.
Sobald der Feuchtigkeitssensor
auf Feuchtigkeit setzt.
Wobei es da vielleicht Probleme
mit Regen und sowas gibt.
Ansonsten gibt es bestimmt
noch weitere Varianten.
Aber ich glaube,
ein Ultraschallsensor dürfte
funktionieren.
Stromverbrauch ist mega gering.
Da braucht man ja gar keinen Strom.
Außer beim Schalten da oben.
Ist schon eine coole Sache.
Wir sehen einen Schlitten
mit einem Fensterkontakt,
der per Wäscheklammer
auf eine Einwegpfandflasche
geklebt wurde.
Das ist, sagen wir mal,
zunehmende Technik.
Ein gut einminütiges Video.
Und jede Einsendung bekommt
einen 50 Euro Amazon Gutschein.
Wenn ihr auch irgendwas habt,
was ihr mir zukommen lassen wollt.
Solche Sorten von Sensoren gibt es
doch garantiert auch schon fix und fertig, oder?
Was in der Richtung?
Ob ihr einfach euer Leergut recycelt
oder irgendeine komplexe
Shortcut, Smart Home,
was auch immer Automation gebaut habt.
Werft die gerne unter
zeug.coolslash zeigen
und vielleicht seid ihr in einer der nächsten
Folgen auch dabei.
Vielleicht könnte man sogar was mit einem Schalter machen.
Vielleicht könnte man auch wirklich was mit einem Schalter machen.
Einen ganz normalen
Schalter.
Das müssen wir mal überlegen.
Lichtschranke. Irgendwas gibt bestimmt
einige Varianten.
Gucken wir mal.
Sensor.
Ja.
Level-Sensoren. Schwimmer.
Niveau-Schalter.
Wasserpegelsensor.
Guck hier, sowas.
Gucken wir mal bei Amazon.
Ja.
Ja okay, die Sachen gibt es fix und fertig schon.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie es funktioniert.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ah, hier, guck.
Rechts, da schaltet es dann ein.
Ja, eigentlich eine richtig coole Sache.
Ja.
Und den Kontakt wahrscheinlich 3,3
Volt oder so, dann kannst du es überall...
Ach Quatsch, du brauchst ja gar...
keinen Sensor in dem Sinn. Das ist einfach
ein Schalter.
Das ist einfach ein Schalter.
Das stimmt, das mit Akkubetrieb.
Wobei man so einen Schalter tatsächlich
auch an einen modifizierten Fensterkontakt
anschließen könnte.
Das wird auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen langlebiger sein.
Als
die Heißkleber-Konstruktion, die er da
am Start hatte.
Dann ist der für ein einminütiges Video
in diesem Fall ganz gut.
Wir haben eine smarte Zugangssteuerung
für Hasen gebaut. Ich weiß nicht, ob die
dann so eine RFID-Karte haben.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Wir schauen uns das mal an.
Was, die Hasen werden gesteuert?
Unsere smarte Zugangssteuerung
für unsere Hasen vorstellen, mit der über
Homematic IP bzw. HomeKit
der Zugang zum Freilaufgehege den Hasen
ermöglicht wird.
Dazu habe ich mir ursprünglich aus dem
Fachhandel eine Rückstau-Klappe
besorgt, welche allerdings
vom Durchmesser nicht gepasst hatte,
die Klappenlösung davon demontiert
habe und auf das vorhandene
Rohr, was wir bereits als Verbindungselement
eingebaut hatten, angebaut habe.
Die Ansteuerung des handelsüblichen
Modellbahnservos, welches
die Klappe, wenn jetzt der Hase dazwischen
steckt, entsprechend
öffnet und schließt, erfolgt über
eine Homematic IP Servo-Kontrollsteuerung,
die es ermöglicht, bis zu
zwei Servos unabhängig voneinander
anzusteuern. Eine lokale Bedienung der
Klappe ist durch einen batteriebetriebenen
Homematic IP Wandtaster vor Ort möglich,
er mit einem Tastendruck die Klappe bewegt.
Gegenwärtig wird die
Da oben ist der Hase, da traut er
Sache noch nicht so ganz.
Kritischer Hase sozusagen.
Zugangssteuerung mit einer Teilautomation betrieben,
das bedeutet, der Verschluss erfolgt
manuell über den Taster von
dem oder derjenigen, die am Abend den
steilen Ordnung bringen und am Morgen
erfolgt zum Sonnenaufgang über eine Zeit
Die Homematic-Steuerung
sieht schon oldschool
aus.
Zeitgesteuerte Routine, automatisch
das Öffnen der Klappe. Sehr spannend, da haben
wir die Tiere aus dem Titel dieses Formats
auch direkt abgefrühstückt,
also abgehandelt. Ich hoffe,
deine Hasen finden nicht raus, wie sie den
Schalter da oben drücken und dein ganzes
Konzept irgendwie zum
Zusammenbrechen bringen können.
Das scheint aber bisher ja nicht aufgetreten zu sein.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall ganz
interessant und ich weiß,
dass die Frage,
ob man Tiere rein oder raus lässt,
euch schon länger beschäftigt.
Also ich lasse Chico ganz
einfach rein und raus, indem ich die Tür auf und zu mache.
Ich habe zwar eine Katzenklappe, aber ich
mache trotzdem die Tür auf und zu.
Kommt ja nicht so oft vor.
Stellen gesehen in Kaninchenstellen.
Und ich hatte die Frage auch neulich mit Katzenbesitzern,
da gibt es ja irgendwie diese Katzenklappen mit RFID-Erkennung.
Ja, ganz ehrlich,
Chico geht an die Tür von innen, macht
Mau-Mau-Mau, ich will raus, dann mache ich die Tür auf.
Ich gucke ab und zu mal raus oder auf die Kamera,
die deckt ja die Tür auch ab.
Wenn ich sehe, dass Chico vor der Tür sitzt, mache ich die Tür
halt auf und dann kommt Chico wieder rein.
Welche Katze da gerade rein will?
Ich weiß nicht, ob Hasen
gechippt werden. Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich bin bei Haustieren im Moment noch etwas
ungeleckt?
Unbeleckt? Unbefleckt?
Apropos Hasen.
Hasen, schon gesehen,
wer das heutige Video sponsern soll.
So, das kleine Problem ist, das heutige Video hat
überhaupt keinen Sponsor. Ich wollte nur diese fantastische
Überleitung nicht
verschwenden. Nice. Stattdessen
möchte ich dich an dieser Stelle einfach auf meinen
Newsletter hinweisen, den ich einmal im Monat
schreibe, den Spiel und Zeug Insider,
wo ich so ein bisschen Einblicke hinter die Kulisse mache.
Was ich sonst so mache, was mich gerade bewegt,
was ich mir an Equipment kaufe
und
ja, was so Gedanken für die Zukunft sind.
Das klingt tiefsinniger als
es ist. Es ist ein bisschen Unfug,
ist ein bisschen Therapiesession für mich.
Wenn euch das interessiert, dann tragt euch gerne
ein, ist kostenlos. Ihr könnt jederzeit gehen, wenn
es euch nicht mehr interessiert.
Schaut doch mal vorbei. Jetzt zurück
zu euren Automationen. So, weiter geht's mit Sascha.
Der möchte uns pumpenloses
Rasenspringen näher bringen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt. Als
jemand, der vielleicht im letzten Jahr
die Pumpe ein bisschen
...
Ja.
So ungefähr
sah mal mein Hochdruckreiniger aus.
Der hatte wohl noch ein bisschen Restwasser
drin und ist dann auch gefroren.
Und dann habe ich ihn angemacht, dann hat es erst mal gemacht
...
und ist
komplett abgesoffen,
das ganze Ding.
Also aus allen möglichen Löchern rausgesprudelt,
wo es nicht raussprudeln soll.
Wie da?
Ja, Wüste. Das habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Ein Schwimmerschalter.
So, weiter geht's
mit Sascha. Der möchte uns
pumpenloses Rasenspringen
näher bringen. Da bin ich sehr gespannt.
Als jemand, der vielleicht
im letzten Jahr die Pumpe ein bisschen
...
Wie immer das Problem von der Rasen
so aussieht.
Ja, gut.
Es ist ja auch sehr trocken gerade.
Also, jetzt gerade nicht, aber es war
lange sehr trocken. Jetzt wird es ja wieder
ein bisschen mehr sommerlich. Wie da?
Ja, Wüste.
Aber ist ja eigentlich auch
nicht schlimm, wenn es trocken ist, dass der Rasen
halt auch ausgetrocknet. Ich meine, was?
Okay, so sieht es halt aus, wenn es
warm ist.
Entweder ...
Also, ich finde, ehrlich gesagt,
meine persönliche Meinung. Ich finde, Rasen
wässern uns das komplett verschwendet.
Einfach trocken lassen,
wenn es trocken ist, und sobald es regnet, ist das Ding wieder
instant grün.
...
Du lässt jetzt aber nicht einfach deinen Whirlpool da ab, oder?
Das wäre ein bisschen, also, ein bisschen geschummelt,
würde ich sagen.
...
und somit die Sonne schon aufgegangen ist und über den Azimut, ob in der jeweiligen Himmelsrichtung
die Sonne steht, sodass sie ins Fenster überhaupt hineinscheinen kann, weil sonst ist die Beschattung
ja gar nicht notwendig. Das Ganze prüfe ich außen die Temperatur mit einer... Der Sonnenstand, okay.
...medic-weather-Station. Ich habe auch eine Hysterese eingebaut, dass die Rollos nicht
automatisch die ganze Zeit fahren und wenn die Sonnenposition außerhalb des Azimutes gewandert
ist, fahren dann auch die Rollos automatisch wieder hoch. Für die Balkontür gibt es dann nochmal einen
Sonderfall. Die Balkontür fährt auch auf 50% Beschattungsposition, wenn der Azimut übereinstimmt.
Allerdings ist hier ja der Sonderfall, dass man auf dem Balkon auch mal natürlich laufen will,
wenn gerade die Beschattung drin ist. Deshalb kann ich mal kurz demonstrieren. Sobald der Griff
gedreht wird, fährt automatisch das Rollo nach oben und das Ganze funktioniert natürlich auch
wieder, wenn man den Griff wieder zurück in die geschlossene Position bringt. Wie bekommt er den Stand des Griffes mit?
Wenn man in die geschlossene Position dreht, hat natürlich auch den charmanten Vorteil, dass man sich nicht aussperrt, wenn man
auf dem Balkon sitzt, da der Griff ja dann automatisch in der geöffneten Position ist.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ganz spannend. Wie bekommt er denn jetzt mit, dass der Griff gedreht ist? War da irgendein Kontakt?
Der Sonnenstand und der Aussperrverriegelung. Also die ganze Thematik mit dem Sonnenstand wirklich an der
genauen Position des Hauses mit aufzunehmen. Das ist sehr Fallfett. Das habe ich jetzt neulich zum ersten Mal so richtig wahrgenommen,
als der Eve Shutter Switch. Der hat in der App eine Funktion, dass man sein Handy an die Fensterfront
hält und er durch den Winkel und den Kompass und weiß ich nicht, schwarze Magie so ein bisschen,
bestimmt in welche Richtung das Fenster gerichtet ist und dann eben abhängig von solchen Sachen
auch die Automation fahren kann. Und ich hatte auch schon mit Kai, der die Elektroplanung für
unser neues Haus macht, darüber gesprochen, dass wir vermutlich auch irgendwie sowas in der Art
zum Beispiel für die Beschattung im Wohnzimmer machen müssen, weil unser Fernseher dem Fenster
zugewandt ist. Ah ja, okay. Wobei das hier kein Problem ist. Da scheint keine Sonne rein ins Wohnzimmer.
Als Vorsitzender habe ich immer das Fenster im Rücken. Also nicht zu Zeitpunkten, wo man Fernsehen guckt.
Und gerade wenn man Presenzmelder im Wohnzimmer hat, kann man sagen, okay, da ist jemand im Fernsehbereich und passt das hier nach Sonnenstand und Wetterlage
und weiß ich nicht was an. Aber finde ich auf jeden Fall sehr spannend. Auch das Zusammenspiel mit der
Schutzmechanik, dass du auf dem Balkon nicht ausgesperrt wirst, ist natürlich dann auch sehr hilfreich.
So, Patrick hat ein Paketkasten mit Nuki Opener öffnen Video geschickt.
Hallo Andreas. Und zwar wollte ich dir meinen Paketkasten zeigen von DHL damals. Und viele kennen das ja auch. DHL hat ja irgendwann den Service eingestellt.
Man konnte es nicht mehr mit dem Handy öffnen. Und wenn man die Chips verliert mittlerweile, kriegt man auch keine neuen mehr.
Jetzt habe ich den Paketkasten. Und mein DHL hat sowas mal angeboten, hat aber den Service eingestellt. Oder habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Die Chips auch. DHL hat ja irgendwann den Service eingestellt. Man konnte es nicht mehr mit dem Handy öffnen. Und wenn man die Chips verliert...
Da sehen wir mal wieder, dass zu viel Cloud Service oftmals halt keine gute Idee ist. Stell dir mal vor, du kriegst deinen Briefkasten nicht mehr auf,
weil irgendein Cloud Service eingestellt wurde. Fast so geil wie letztens. Du kannst das Licht an deinem Fahrrad nicht mehr einschalten, weil kein Cloud Service mehr...
Mittlerweile kriegt man auch keine neuen mehr. Jetzt habe ich den Paketkasten smart umgebaut. Und zwar habe ich das mit Nuki gemacht. Hier vorne ist ein Nuki-K-Pad.
Wo die Zugangscode für DHL, Hermes und die ganzen Paketdienste, wo jeder seinen eigenen Code für hat. Hier habe ich noch...
Moment. Und wie kann man den Paketdiensten den Code übermitteln? Haben die da irgendwie so ein Formular oder wie? Der Fahrer muss das ja auch wissen.
Moment. Man kann jedem Paketdiensten einen eigenen Code geben? Gut, ich möchte aber nicht, dass die bei uns die Haustür aufmachen.
Wenn man dann den PIN eingibt, dann leuchtet hier oben noch eine LED und der Paketkasten öffnet sich. Das Ganze habe ich realisiert über einen normalen Türkontakt, der über 12 Volt läuft.
Hier auf der Gegenseite habe ich einfach ein Türschloss angebaut. Oder ja, mit Schrauben halt. Ein normales Türschloss, wo ich die Falle rausgenommen habe und nur der Kontakt für die andere Falle, für das Gegenstück da ist.
Da müsste man den Lockpicking-Lawyer dranlassen, wie lange das hält. Dann habe ich hier oben, sitzt nämlich das ganze Hauptstück. Ja, mit einer Hand ein bisschen schwierig. So. Und hier habe ich dann einfach von der Nuvi den K-Opener genommen.
Ich hätte viel zu sehr bedenken, dass das einfach irgendwann den Geist aufgibt und der Typ das Paket nicht reinbekommt.
Als Summer verbunden und die Öffnung für den Summer, das Plus- und Minus-Kabel, was den Summer öffnet, habe ich mit einer LED verbunden, die vorne dann hier leuchtet, sobald der Summer geöffnet wird.
Das ganze habe ich dann hier an einen Stromkabel mit einem Netzteil für 12 Volt verbunden und so kann man das Gerät auch enden.
So ein Netzteil ist mir letztens abgeraucht, hatte ich im Keller auch so an so ein schaltbares, also so ein, wo man verschiedene Spannungen wechseln kann.
Habe ich rein und raus gesteckt und auf einmal hat es gesagt, Puff, Sicherung im Keller raus, Licht aus, alles aus.
Hat den Geist aufgegeben.
Du scheinst eine sehr große Kanone auf diese Spatzen ausgepackt zu haben, also wie ein Paketbriefkasten mit Nuki-Opener und mit dem Keypad, ist mir bisher noch nicht untergekommen.
Aber auf jeden Fall ist auch da mein Plan eine Paketbox zu installieren in Zukunft, weil ich doch das ein oder andere Paket bekomme.
Also bei uns ist es ganz einfach, Amazon hat keine Ablegevereinbarung oder wie auch immer man das nennt und auch keine Hinweise.
Amazon schmeißt das einfach immer übers Hoftor, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Nicht, weil ich das mit denen so abgesprochen habe, sondern weil die keinen Bock haben, das wieder mitzunehmen.
Das liegt dann einfach hinterm Hoftor.
Warte ich schon öfter, das liegt dann einfach so rum, egal ob es regnet oder so, das liegt dann einfach hinterm Hoftor.
Wenn ihr Erfahrungen an der Front habt oder du, dann schreibt sie gerne unten rein.
So, Olaf hat was geschickt, auch hier geht es um Garten.
Aber bis jetzt ist noch nie, wobei ich weiß nicht, ob es noch nie war, ich kann mich zumindest nicht dran erinnern, also selten war es kaputt gegangen.
Also wie gesagt, noch nie, du wirst es jetzt nicht.
Schauen wir mal rein, was Olaf anders macht.
Alter, mein Ohr!
Das ist meine smarte Gartenbewässerung, die mittlerweile seit zwei Jahren ohne Probleme läuft.
Ja, bitte leiser reden und mehr Außengeräusche.
Den Sprungkopf habe ich in Fusion 360 konstruiert.
Oh, selbst 3D-Druck, krasser Dude, Alter!
Das sieht auch richtig gut aus, oder?
Hast du selbst gedruckt? Oder hast du eine Kamera, die die einzelnen Layer in diesem Fall verschluckt?
Ich glaube, das liegt am Material, in was er gedruckt hat, aber das ist wirklich gut geworden, muss man sagen.
Also hier oben sieht man es vielleicht ein bisschen, das ist gut, ja doch, hier unten sieht man es, aber das ist gut geworden.
Weiß, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Fonso, ja, das könnte bei uns auch passieren, die Pfeffernass über das Tor drüber und fertig.
Ein Stück gedruckt, hast du selbst gedruckt? Oder hast du eine Kamera, die die einzelnen Layer in diesem Fall verschluckt?
Ich habe jetzt übrigens auch so eine Fitness-Uhr, ich habe keine Apple Watch, ich habe eine Garmin-Uhr, weil die einfach akutechnisch länger hält.
Und ich muss sagen, das ist tatsächlich echt motivierend, damit zu tracken.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt auch Muskelkarte als Fuck.
Oder ist es die YouTube-Kompression?
Jetzt haben wir einen handelsüblichen Gardena-Anschluss.
In der Mitte steht der Sprühkopf auf einem.
Ja, da fehlt einer noch Gardena auf USB.
Ein Alu-Stab, der in der Höhe je nach Pflanzenart variierbar ist.
Wie bei jedem Bewässerungssystem kommt es darauf an, wie viel Druck noch am Ende da ist.
Das ist bei jeder Frage im Leben, oder?
Hier ist es so, dass ich von diesen Sprühköpfen sechs in eine Reihe schalten kann.
Mit einem Abstand von ca. zweieinhalb bis drei Metern.
Äh, das funktioniert nicht, den Fiat Champ für Garmin.
Der Sprühkopf selbst sprüht im Radius von ungefähr 1,50 Meter und in einem Halbkreis.
Weil die Garmin-Uhr, also bei einer Uhr mit WLAN vielleicht, dass du halt auf den Service zugreifen könntest.
Das habe ich so über einen Verteiler realisiert, von dem ich mir gedacht habe,
Olaf hat auch die Pläne mitgeschickt.
Die könnt ihr euch auch über den Link in der Videobeschreibung runterladen.
Für 2,50 Euro verkauft er die Bauanleitung und dann könnt ihr euch logischerweise so viel davon drucken, wie ihr braucht.
Ja, naja, und Ersatzteile, wenn irgendwann mal was kaputt geht, kann man einfach neu wieder drucken.
Interessant, vielen Dank dafür.
Das 3D-Modell würde ich schon mal angucken.
Okay, ne, hier sieht man schon, dass die Garmin-Uhr, also bei einer Uhr mit WLAN vielleicht,
aber es ist gut geworden, was er da gebaut hat.
Sehr Pog.
Und dieses 3D-gedruckte Zeug ist erstaunlich widerstandsfähig.
Endlich wieder 3D-gedruckte Sachen.
Moin, Moin, Sauerstadt. Neue 3D-Schmollader.
Pog. Das ist extrem.
Aber das 3D-gedruckte Zeug hält länger, als man so denkt.
Ultimative Urlaubsweg.
Also ich würde sagen, die Ventile und so, die gehen wahrscheinlich eher kaputt,
oder die Dichtungen gehen eher kaputt, bevor das 3D-gedruckte Zeug kaputt ist.
Das ist wirklich sehr stabil.
Ich habe ja auch ein paar 3D-gedruckte Sachen im Einsatz, das echt passt.
Ich habe zum Beispiel ein ganzes Regal hängen, nur an 3D-gedruckten Sachen.
Funs, kein Problem.
Werkzeug für Haustierbesitzer, den Futterautomat von David für seine Katzen.
Das Original, wie es einmal gebaut war,
eigentlich recht simpel, hier war einfach nur ein Uhrwerk drin,
was man hier bis auf 48 Stunden drehen konnte,
und dann sollte das ganze Teil aufgehen.
Problem war, so ganz genau war das nicht einzustellen.
Ich habe das manchmal, wenn man es auf 4 Stunden gestellt hat, ging es...
Ja, das sieht ja auch noch richtig oldschool-analog aus.
War schon nach 3 auf, manchmal war es nach 6 Stunden auf.
Und ich wusste natürlich auch nicht wirklich, ob es aufgegangen ist,
wenn ich nicht zu Hause bin.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, das Ganze machen wir doch einfach mal smart.
Und hier sieht man das gut auf der anderen Seite, schön im Vergleich.
Ist das ein SwitchBot?
Mit Heißkleber draufgeklebt, ein SwitchBot?
Ein SwitchBot, wie heißt der?
Ich glaube, da heißt es einfach nur SwitchBot.
Das war nämlich der allererste SwitchBot, dieser Schalterding.
Eigentlich hat der Futterautomat zwei Fächer und hat auch zwei Einstellmöglichkeiten.
Da wir aber zwei Katzen haben, gehen wir...
Hat er trotzdem zwei?
Sollen bei uns immer beide Fächer gleichzeitig aufgehen,
deswegen habe ich das ganz einfach verbunden mit dem Deckel.
Der Vorteil ist, ich brauche auch nur eine Seite umbauen und das regelt sofort beides.
Ja, wie habe ich das gemacht?
Ihr seht schon, hier habe ich einen SwitchBot-Bot verbaut,
der quasi die Verriegelung übernimmt und das öffnet, wenn ich das möchte.
Zusätzlich habe ich hier einen Kontaktschalter.
Der ist verbunden mit einem Acara-Tür- und Fenstersensor.
Das habe ich deswegen nochmal zusätzlich gemacht,
damit ich auch wirklich eine Nachricht bekomme, wenn es geöffnet worden ist.
Es kann ja auch mal passieren, dass irgendwas streikt,
der SwitchBot nicht richtig funktioniert.
Dann kann ich das nochmal manuell nachauslösen, wenn es nicht geklappt haben sollte.
Ja, wie funktioniert das Ganze?
Recht simpel, Futter rein, natürlich.
Klappe wird geschlossen.
Dann ist der automatisch verriegelt.
Eigentlich eine recht simple, coole Sache, was er da gebaut hat.
Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass das sonderlich viel Krafteinwirkung standhalten würde.
Gerade auf der Seite, wo das ja nur hiermit verbunden ist.
Also wenn die Katze es auf der Seite aufkriegen will und weiß,
dass sie da eigentlich nur ordentlich genug dran ziehen muss,
vielleicht wird sie das hinkriegen.
Und dann gehe ich zu unserem Tablet im Wohnzimmer,
gehe auf unsere Einstellungsseite und habe hier den Futterautomat.
Kann dann Uhrzeit einstellen, aktuell ist 16 Uhr eingestellt und gehe auf Programmieren.
Damit weiß mein Smart Home, um 16 Uhr soll ich die Katzen füttern.
Soweit, so einfach.
Ja, da es bis 16 Uhr jetzt noch nicht geklappt hat,
werde ich das Ganze jetzt einfach einmal manuell auslösen, um euch das zu zeigen.
Dauert ein paar Sekunden.
Cool.
Wegen der Bluetooth-Verbindung geht das nicht ganz so schnell,
aber ich bekomme sofort eine Nachricht.
Also eine an sich recht simple Konstruktion.
Coole Sache, ja.
Katzen sind gefüttert.
Ich weiß Bescheid, wenn ich unterwegs bin,
dass ich mir da keine Sorgen drum machen könnte.
Man könnte aber auch einfach ein bisschen Trockenfutter in der Wohnung verteilen.
Ich meine, Chico, also ich kann euch nicht sagen, wie es bei Chico ist.
Chico hat hier oben Trockenfutter, hat im Wohnzimmer Trockenfutter,
hat unten im Flur Trockenfutter.
Und die läuft den ganzen Tag rum und futtert mal hier ein bisschen,
mal da ein bisschen und sowieso.
Also da ist überhaupt nichts, wo ich irgendwie ein Fütterautomat bräuchte.
Die kriegt, also wenn die wirklich Hunger hat,
die kriegt natürlich, wenn sie unterwegs ist,
die kriegt morgens ein bisschen Futter, also nasses Futter.
Die kriegt mittags und abends auch noch ein bisschen nasses Futter,
immer wenn sie will.
Also Chico macht das eigentlich so,
genau wie Katzen in der freien Wildbahn das auch machen.
Die frisst mehrfach am Tag kleine Portionen.
Also ich bräuchte gar kein Futterautomat für die.
Zumindest nicht, wenn ich nur einen Tag weg bin.
Natürlich, wenn du jetzt zwei Katzen hast und nur zwei Fächer,
dann ist das ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber ich würde sagen,
natürlich, wenn du jetzt zwei Katzen hast und nur zwei Fächer,
ist das wahrscheinlich jetzt eher für den Tagestrip als für den Urlaub.
Ja, bei mir liegt genug Futter für den ganzen Tag.
Das interessiert Chico nicht.
Chico geht hin, wenn sie Hunger hat, frisst ein bisschen was und geht wieder weg.
Die frisst nicht alles auf einmal.
Ein bisschen zu weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt bei der Ankündigung.
Aber ich nehme das mal so mit.
Ich habe auch keine Katzen.
Ich nehme das mal so mit, das ist die 0815-Aussage für jedes Meeting,
wenn man was machen soll.
Und die nächsten Wochen kann man dann immer erzählen, da bin ich dran.
Ich kann das also nicht so genau einschätzen.
Aber ich meine, es gibt auch Futterautomaten,
die das von Haus aus portionieren,
damit man das über mehrere Tage machen kann.
Ja, automatisch schließen kann das nicht.
Weil hier könntest du ja auch Nassfutter reintun.
Also hier kannst du ja alles reintun.
Wenn ihr was für eure Haustiere gebaut habt,
dann schmeißt es gerne bei zeug.co.
Gerade wenn es auch vielleicht für mehrere Tage ist.
Dann können wir das in einer der nächsten Folgen aufrollen.
Oder wenn ihr irgendwas völlig anderes gebaut habt.
Wenn ihr ein Bett habt, das euch morgens rauskippt,
wenn der Wecker klingelt.
Oder...
Oh, das wollte ich auch mal gucken.
Aber ein, drei Spiele sind mir jetzt zu lang.
Leute, ich muss aufs Klo.
Und danach muss ich was essen.
Ich habe mega Hunger.
Zu viel Sport gemacht.
Und Muskelkater habe ich auch noch.
Ich gehe jetzt schon auf.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich heute Nachmittag noch mal am Start.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.